I really can't say I'm surprised that
Ron DeSantis has shattered the minds of
these these Urban liberal types of the
media
let me just tell you very quickly in the
span of 24 hours we went from Ron
DeSantis is effectively putting these
people like like treating him like it's
the Holocaust to we are going to show
you just how how proud and supportive we
are of migrants to calling in the
National Guard and now NBC had to delete
a tweet calling these people trash
saying that Rhonda Santos was throwing
his trash around
it's it's it's the meme okay do you guys
remember the gag from Babylon B Donald
ingenious move Donald Trump supports
impeachment forcing Democrats to oppose
this is what's this it's just it's true
it's real it's a thing I'm surprised I
would like to make one request as we
start the show Ron DeSantis you are you
are a legend good sir it was a brilliant
move that exposed the hypocrisy of those
who vote for failed policies that are
causing us harm damage and economic
Strife I just implore that you do it
more Martha's Vineyard is beautiful this
time of year there are tons of empty
airbnbs and summer homes and if they
wanted to they could pay the 200 to put
a family in one of these houses on the
above board on the level right through
Airbnb but for some reason they call the
National Garden and now they're sending
these people to a Detention Center at a
military base okay I don't know if it's
actually a detention center but to a
military base that is the warmth these
people claim to have for the immigrants
yeah well the Santa's he sure he's
certainly exposed that we're going to
talk about that in a bunch of other
crazy stories but first my friends head
over to timcast.com and become a member
to support our work directly you guys
you're going to want to watch the the
members only show last night with Alex
Stein and Ryan Walters and the episode
last night with Alex Stein because the
Dude is hilarious and he did the one
chip challenge with a lot we had good
fun support our work at timcast.com our
journalists are working day and night
we're hiring more
and the journalism uh Venture of this
website is is just membership funded so
it is it is really just you choose to
support our journalists and if you do
they can keep writing there's not a lot
of money in news we are working on other
shows cast Castle Vlog has a bunch of
guest cameos and new episodes coming out
and we're working on getting a better
improving audio and and the writing and
everything so with your support we're
going to keep making things making
awesome things so don't forget to also
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and more is Dr Drew
thank you guys welcome so glad to be
here not easy to be here either out in
the middle of nowhere yeah middle of
nowhere so what a privilege oh thanks
for coming man we're honored to have you
uh who are you uh yeah I'm Dr dupinski
uh I did a show for many years called
Loveline uh I'm an internist a
dictionologist practice medicine for 40
years and alongside of that started
doing media and about uh you know more
recently I'm doing a lot of digital
stuff I have a streaming show on Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday particularly the
Wednesday show this group would be
interested and I've been talking to all
the people that have been silenced uh by
various other organizations I just want
to hear what they have to say because
many of them are very highly acclaimed
professionals and they were marginalized
for no good reason as far as I can tell
well this is actually uh how I ended up
reaching out to you because you got just
you got censored on YouTube yep and your
doctor Drew yeah and and you weren't
talking about anything off the rails
they just robot it was an algorithm it
was an AI thing yeah it's a it's an
algorithm it's nailed me and I've been
tagged by it before and then then I get
this site gets taken down it gets taken
out for periods of time but we now have
a relationship with a human at YouTube
and so they told us that the their main
concerns were sort of with the
Therapeutics and and they were okay with
Physicians talking which has been great
because now I've talked to Paul
Alexander and Harvey rich and Peter
McCullough and Robert Malone and hear
what these guys have to say and it's
helped me put together you know during
covet 90 of the time for the first year
I was like what is going on here what is
going on I could not figure it out and
um started starting to put it together
slowly but surely it's very culty just
marching lockstep with whatever the
approved narrative it was unbelievable
and and uh and Harvey Reese said
something just uh this Wednesday at
three o'clock Pacific time so do tune in
on that if you don't mind us doctor.tv
doctor drew.com I'm sure you guys and
we'll get into all this other stuff too
so but but I talked to Dr Harvey rich
and he said it was Psychopathic the way
Physicians behave sending patients home
until they came back with a po2 of 85.
just go home until you can't breathe
what's po2 the auction saturation it's
like when in the history of medicine has
the proper practice of medicine babe we
can't do anything just get out of here
come back when you can't breathe that's
what they told me that was insane I
called Joe Rogan and then he was like
you got to talk to a different doctor
man like here's the treatment that I did
and then sure enough like 12 hours after
getting the treatment the monoclonal
antibody which everybody is free and
everyone has access to them I I got them
myself too I got very sick with kova for
Delta and I and I uh got monoclonal
antibiotics I have like physician
working for me and uh you know with me
and a great guy and he set him up within
three days and while while I was getting
the infusion I felt better like
literally colors got brighter in the
room during the monoclonal antibody
infusion and so I went on Instagram live
and said listen everybody the Public
Health Community should be teaching you
how to deal with your illness here's
something you need to know the stuff is
free it's available and everybody was
like oh you're special you got special
treatment because you could pay for it
no it's available they had a half a
million doses sitting on the shelf back
then we'll get into all this all right
all right okay yeah yeah we also got
Luke hanging out all right Physicians
talking to each other freely blasphemy
we should only trust Dr fauci and of
course Bill Gates who's pictured here
very lovingly on my t-shirt saying trust
us and if you agree with this message
that I'm trying to send you you could
get the shirt on the best political show
arts.com but I agree with you guys I was
here Tim when you were going through
your thing I was like dude you got to
call somebody to get antibodies and
there's so many different things that we
could get into I'm very excited for this
conversation Dr Drew thank you so much
for coming here you've been better to
call than Joe Rogan I mean he's he's the
The Trusted knows all seasonal and also
since we have a real medical doctor here
it's also important to remind everyone
Bill Gates is not a medical doctor yes
I'm not going to say that for the record
and of course Ian has returned hello
everyone I'm sitting here in Alex
Stein's uh microphone where it still
smells like Alex in a chip just I'm just
kidding Drew I love you life uh Love
Line changed my life in my early teens
you know 11 12 13. it means a lot to us
got to hang out and listen after late
night and about learning about sex from
actual experts it was oh and Adam I
guess he's an expert in his own right
like we used to call it back in the day
we call it the gainsburg on the pill he
was the games burger that wrapped the
pill in it was me and it was such a good
get it in that way
um I also had that monoclonal thing in
it within an hour I don't know I felt
better it's crazy hey I want to point
this out before we get started this is
my book you can get it on Amazon writing
in the dark look at the font look at the
color and this is cloud Schwab's book
it'll be just released I released mine
10 years ago I just I I just wow I love
the thought of Klaus Schwab he's like
sitting there reading his book he's like
this is very good I want to do this yeah
come on so we're gonna work together me
and Klaus and we're gonna help build a
new world government whether you guys
like it or not it's happening it's just
a matter about doing it decentralized
that other book this other book is
genderqueer this comes up on the show
from time to time this book was pulled
out of Florida schools I just I just
real quick quick if we showed you what's
in this book we'd probably get taken off
yeah
it's very extreme young kids doing
sexual things and it was in schools so
there's a big Hub of blue about it don't
don't show it don't babies talk about it
on an after show one of these things but
I had to get a copy of myself just in
case they end up trying to digitally
retcon this thing I wanna I want it in
the print smart yeah I'm Ian Crossing by
the way what up let's get going I'm very
excited for this evening because like
Ian I used to listen to Dr Drew late at
night I had a lot of questions because I
was homeschooled my family was super
Conservative Christian so a lot of my
quick questions answered
all right our first store we got this
from The Daily Caller NBC deletes tweet
comparing immigrants to trash I just you
know I didn't expect it to go this far
so quickly so fast Ronda Santa sent 50
illegal immigrants to Martha's Vineyard
and it was like a political nuclear bomb
take a look at this
NBC tweeted Florida Governor DeSantis
sending Asylum Seekers to Martha's
Vineyard is like quote me taking my
trash out and just driving to different
areas where I live and just throwing my
trash there a founding member of a
foundation which helps refugees says wow
that is a not only indicative of NBC
News is what they're willing to publish
because they didn't need to choose that
quote but also these ngos these these
non-profits that claim to help these
people you see what they really think
about them it reminds me of when uh that
Osborne woman was on The View or
whatever
Deport these people who's going to clean
your toilet and they were like you
remember that yeah that's what she said
right yeah specifically she asked Donald
Trump uh going against Donald Trump's
immigration policy quote who will clean
your toilet when you Deport he couldn't
he's even like the white woman that I
hired to clean my toilet next question
yeah you know many nothing not not
people don't know is many refugees from
multiple countries most countries that
you come in here as an assault Seeker
you're required to take for a week in
anti-helmenthic medication that starts
with an eye you're required by the CDC
to take that medication for a week and
that's because it's what you're talking
about ivermectins because it's a worms a
worm because it's so worms it's so
common in many of the Asylum Seekers
that they're acquired by the CDC to take
it for a week really so Asylum Seekers
coming in your parasites have are given
Ivermectin yes wow mandatory for a week
wow that's do you look it up on the CDC
website just look at look at a look at
the refugees the CDC cbcdc Refugee uh uh
you know therapeutic recruitment yeah
Ivermectin is an incredible medication
that has saved countless numbers of
lives used billions of times and it
comes from the soil in Japan and we
could get into this Opera we're going to
get into this topic a little bit but uh
we're just seeing there it is yeah look
at that all Middle Eastern Asian North
African Latin American and Caribbean
refugees should receive Ivermectin two
doses 200 was it micrograms per kilogram
yeah orally once a day for two days
before departure to the US that's really
interesting I didn't know that yeah well
um required CDC we got a doctor here so
there we go yeah and um it's crazy what
are we going to do now call it horse
medicine and say the CDC is forcing
right because one of the things that
bother me with that whole horse medicine
thing is every
pharmacological agent has a Veterinary
application why aren't we talking about
pepcids a Veterinary pepsin it's a
Veterinary pill you can get over the
counter at a pharmacy we we talked about
this weird um epinephrine yeah sheep
epinephrine is cheaper than the human
epinephrine granted the the human
epipens are like single dose instant
shots or whatever whereas like you can
buy a vial of the sheep stuff but don't
do it do not do it do not take
Veterinary medication the point is
though why this one medicine I I really
tried to figure out where it came from I
guess one couple tried it and that there
were multiple calls to poison control
centers asking questions about it but
all I can find is one game well well the
Rolling Stones did a very big
investigative piece about how people in
a hospital in Oklahoma were oding on it
so much that of course it filled up
their emergency rooms and the whole
story was absolutely made up out of
nowhere the Rolling Stone should be
absolutely just graced with themselves
and and just run out of town run out of
business with the way that they lanyard
this this medication that has saved so
many lives in this journalistic I mean
river blindness I've never been a fan uh
since the since the get-go with um kovid
that people have been pushing these
Therapeutics and I felt like it was very
tribal me too well but I do want to say
I am very impressed in how we
immediately shifted from a immigration
story right into Ivermectin and also you
know what do you know about Chinese
liver flukes in the eye why why do you
know about that the river blindness yeah
because when when uh the whole ever
mentioned things oh they discussed it
okay well it's all in the news and it's
it's a rare illness is it like in the
river they would swim into the eyeball
when they're swimming underwater guys it
was called a Chinese liver fluke we used
to look for it in the eye I don't know
how it gets there but it I think in
Africa it's really really common and so
uh Ivermectin is like a un certified
like oh yeah but I want to I want to
stress this too I really do think that
when it came to covet I I did not when I
got kovid this is the craziest thing I
didn't want it I said I didn't want it
yeah they gave me monoclonal antibodies
that that works me up right right and
then four days later they were like well
were your doctor we prescribed it and I
was like but I'm I feel fine now and so
even when I went on Rogan I said I I'm
not you know confident in this because I
know there's a lot of studies but
there's a lot of contradiction let me
just tell you let me just tell you just
real quick my point was The Daily Beast
still ended up writing that I was the
poster boy for Ivermectin despite me
constantly being like nah well let me
add to that being not uh you know back
when we had nothing to offer it's like
all right whatever I saw it used a ton
and it was like people that were getting
sick just kept getting sick they got
worse some people that were gonna get
well got well and I don't know the
medicine made a difference as opposed to
now with paxilvid and monoclone advice
they're better the next day I mean it's
just a power they get better immediately
oh my goodness well too well actually
because you get these rebounds that are
kind of common and I'm wondering if it's
affecting the immune response my
daughter took packs of it better in two
days and then was not rebound but
reinfected six weeks later wow and so
two months later and it was like uh she
should have still been immune but that's
the drug that was also approved under
emergency protocol is that correct and I
think some people are also saying that
their side effects is this taste in
their mouth of crap that they can't get
out from this side effect and also
there's a lot of people who took it like
Joe Biden and I think another very
prominent politician that had a rebound
so still everything's not known and when
it comes to the antibodies we've got to
remember in January the Biden
Administration uh got rid of antibodies
and told everyone not to use it and
prevented people from using it when it
could have saved lives which is
absolutely insane I want to ask you um
do you know the name of the of the
phenomenon when you taste crap in your
mouth and everything tastes like crap
you mean from paxilvid no it's not just
from paxilvid there's a there's a word
oh syndrome
because I remember I remember people
were getting coveted yeah and then like
there's a video of a woman crying saying
everything tastes like sewage that's
rare that's rare usually it just doesn't
taste or taste salty discussions the
Distortion of the sense of taste is that
kind of like disgusting
I guess did they ever figure out what
kovid was doing to people because I
heard that it was somehow causing the
red blood cells to not be able to
transport oxygen yes that's probably
true probably due to microvascular
injury this this something about the
spike protein and the lining of the
endothelium that's where the story is we
don't have it fully worked out yet but
it was causing our tiniest vessels to
dysfunction so nutrients and oxygen and
immune cells so it's a lot of the brain
stuff we've been worrying about is
because of that microvasculature in fact
it's pretty well established that the
whole Factory stuff the smell stuff is
from this microvascular oh that's the
brain fog just really just one more
click there was another study there was
another another rooting this per year
program
one more thing because because this is
such an important thing I can't stop I'm
building the roads this way just really
there's a new study released in the New
England Journal of Medicine a study from
Israel that talked about how paxilovid
had no benefits to people under 65.
that's the earliest that is that has
been that is so so generally with covid
today we know what we're doing with
vaccines over the age of 75 and Pax live
it over 65. otherwise we don't really
fully know what we're doing what is back
by the sense intense of the from us from
a clinical and scientific standpoint we
have we're very clear we're very very
solid you know over 75 over 65 under
that we're gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
throw a lasso around this and yank it
right back
hook out for me
pull it back to uh uh what's going on
with the the immigrations yes look at
that wait a minute but we'll get back
into this too I don't want to like I
don't want to just shut that down we
actually just have a handful of other
stories related to the immigration
crisis it's a new Pfizer drug let me let
me see if I can uh I want to pull up
this tweet and kind of wrap up the
segment so good this is John Hayward to
tweet it's one sending 50 migrants to
Martha's Vineyard is like the Holocaust
too hahaha you just gave us a chance to
show how compassionate we are three we
demand emergency service assistance four
get these damn migrants off Island 5
called the National Guard all in 24
hours this is the red pilling of of what
you know migrancy can become overly
compassionate to a destructive purpose
like yeah the idea of letting people
that are suffering in and helping them
is great but when you actually see what
that means for an infrastructure that
can't handle it it's it can become
destroyed no no no you're wrong the
infrastructure can handle it go on
Airbnb right now and you look at
Martha's Vineyard there's enough houses
that are available there's enough rooms
that are available the Obamas have
enough mansions that are available and
someone said today on Twitter that and
it caught my attention uh I'm sorry
Mansions being one yeah yeah of course
yeah of course but someone said
something on Twitter that really caught
my attention today and it said that the
Democrats have a new immigration policy
and it's quote you don't got to go home
but you can't stay here and that's
exactly what happened in Martha's
Vineyard and it's and it's and and
DeSantis put it right on their doorsteps
and they showed what kind of big
Hypocrites they are it's it's hilarious
unfortunately it's a violation of basic
moral certainly content moral principles
of using people as a means to an end but
it's a problem on all sides yeah I agree
but the issue is that Biden has been
doing it the Biden Administration
trafficking children yeah and so but but
here's the way I see it
for DeSantis we know there's a political
stunt in Martha's Vineyard specifically
I'm not a fan of any of these people
doing it now New York City is sending
them back to Florida it's just outright
crazy but here's the funny thing as they
rag on Abbott and DeSantis over this
Biden's been sending the migrants to New
York City so they completely ignore the
problem when it's Biden doing it sending
them to New York then as soon as Abbott
or DeSantis does it all of a sudden now
it's a humanitarian crisis is that them
or is that the media
what's the difference yeah but there's
blaming like Biden or DeSantis like
isn't it the cartels that are running
human trafficking across our border it
is leftist ngos with U.S influence going
down and telling them the borders open
and jobs are waiting for that that's
right you had mentioned before the show
that it might be big money involved I
don't know if so there's videos we've
seen this during the big Caravans of
people who look American talking and
working with these people and they're
being told that you can come up no one
will stop you and there's jobs waiting
you were saying Ami Horowitz yeah I mean
Horowitz has some good videos on this he
embedded himself he was he said there's
rail cars of food and pods a hospital
and a school it all travels with them I
mean it's thousands of people going
thousands of miles what do you think you
just rely on the the kindness of
strangers as you walk into their Town
foreign's profiting off of it they're
like getting paid it's human trafficking
essentially What's Happening Here
I wouldn't be surprised if there's big
business in the US behind it for cheap
labor things like that we've seen it in
the past well Bernie Sanders called it a
Koch brothers plan a Billionaire's plan
to get a bunch of cheap labor to of
course lower wages and increase the
housing costs for everyone else let me
pull up this story from the daily mail
this is uh Luke had just mentioned this
a moment ago Daily Mail says what
homeless crisis dozens of rooms and
properties are available on Airbnb and
Martha's Vineyard after homelessness
director claimed 50 illegal immigrants
could not stay because there's no
affordable housing it's a big lie they
look pull up Airbnb and you will see the
dozens several dozen properties that are
vacant right now and I I know you might
be saying but Tim those are that's
private property you can't just force
I'm going to force anybody the local
government of all of these very wealthy
individuals who pay very very large
property taxes can spend the two hundred
dollars per night to house these people
until they can find a place for them I
don't see I'm not even trying to be cute
here
if these people showed up and said what
do we do with them okay it's going to
cost us 10 grand we're going to find
them a home for three days to make them
make sure they're comfortable well taken
care of and well fed we can easily
afford the 10 grand then we'll find a
place that's more permanent or a way to
transition them to something more
permanent instead what do they do they
call the National Guard ship them off to
a military base oh they also had a
GoFundMe they started 30
30 series I have another homeless
wrinkle as it pertains to immigration
that it's exposed something which is
that in the city of Los Angeles we have
150 000 people sitting on the streets
lying on the sidewalks sick as hell but
any event uh and we've had roughly 500
000 undocumented workers come into the
city give or take
of those 500 000 people they have no
home no money no family no job no
passport they're there illegally I I
dare you to find one on the street it's
a housing problem and yet people with
that kind of of a of a of a burden find
housing you know they have nothing and
they find housing not one of them on the
street out of 500 000. I used to live in
LA and I worked at a restaurant with
illegal immigrants that were working in
the kitchen and they had like their own
housing structure set up that only they
could live at and it was Dirt Cheap like
100 bucks a month
but they no it's not that so much they'd
live in would they get eight or ten of
them together and they'd get a place you
know they'd go do it and they'd survive
and they'd work real hard and they'd
then they'd move out find another place
I think someone was funding their cheap
rent I I think it was like a an
organization was making sure they had a
place to stay for very cheap that makes
sense
even if you pay even if these companies
are paying illegal immigrants they don't
pay taxes so they say like so if they
pay an illegal immigrant minimum wage it
wasn't my company that I was working at
it was like another illegal immigration
company or group that was like making
sure I don't know I don't know why their
rent was so super cheap in in on Sunset
but he's getting Silver Lake La yeah
kibono is that is that the thing is the
benefits yeah the benefits as Alex Jones
has it all the time key Bono and the
worst part was that they were amazing
people this is what's so crazy yes
but it's just the harsh reality of
putting too many people together at once
I I just it it makes me feel like you
know uh I mentioned this before the show
I mentioned mentioned it earlier on my
other show
um it's the fall of the Roman Republic
not the Roman Empire huh
um and a lot of people have likened
what's happening now to the Roman Empire
and maybe I don't know I was just
reading and I was like oh it sounds like
the Roman Republic like someone comes in
because someone super chatted this
yesterday saying that Caesar Crossing
the Rubicon wasn't the end it was
transforming the Republican to the
Empire which made it last for another
200 you know another two centuries and
so I was thinking about that right you
bring up the homeless problem we've had
a homeless problem in La for what
decades several decades and now we have
Mass immigration problem Mass illegal
immigration problem how are we supposed
to accommodate more people when we can't
even accommodate our own it's just going
to crumble and fall between but we could
accommodate them we refuse to Towers we
actively we actively have laws and
systems that prevent us from treating
these poor people like how would we do
it oh my God it'd be so simple I mean
these are all my patients these are look
if you took that same population and put
them in four walls in a room and they
were dying at the rate they're dying
right now that that's a hospital except
there are no doctors and no nurses and
doctors and nurses are not allowed to
interact with them or deal with them at
all until they get so sick they end up
in the ER and then if they say I have a
place to eat I have two bucks for
McDonald's I have a place to live that's
my tent over there that's it you can't I
don't want to kill myself and somebody
else you can't keep them the hospital
can't keep them no you can't keep it so
so are you saying these are people with
like um drug addiction schizophrenia
bipolar oh it's just a mess it's just
it's just a open-air Asylum now these
people with uh schizophrenia bipolar
disorder if they were given medication
would they Thrive we I worked with the
state senate for a while trying to get
trying to get a law passed to just be to
take the heat off a little bit because
we sent families up there and families
like look I have money I have doctors
ready to go I have a bed for my son
please help me bring him in he doesn't
want to come in because it's part of the
the illness they have something called
anesagnosia they're blocked and seeing
what's going on with them they think
they're living their best life they're
just getting sicker and sicker and they
die and Anna's acknowledges a
neurological term it just means kind of
like denial and uh and they just told
them to scram get out of here get out of
here who are you to say
it's like it's on purpose isn't it yes
it's disgusting
is it terrible why is this why why it's
a you know I I did a documentary called
Beyond homelessness with the Salvation
Army sort of making the rounds now and
the woman that spearheaded that did the
interviews and stuff I was with her at a
film festival I said I said I'm so tired
I just can't do it anymore I can't do it
she goes no please keep going I go I go
I can't fight these guys I know you know
what what can we reason with them and
she turned to me she snapped me she goes
it's a religion for them it's a religion
you can't reason with them I thought oh
great and the religion is people are
free to do whatever there's no such
thing as brain diseases there's no such
thing it affects free will there's no
such thing that affects judgment there's
nothing the only disease is dementia
that one if you don't treat you've
abused a patient and again it is the
same exact symptom complex
abusing Joe Biden and all the studies
and what we knew about dementia was also
artificially inflated by a scientist
that just made science up that was also
a recent scientific finding as well and
Ian you ask why do you think the
government cares about you Ian do you
think the government ever cares about
you or do you think they're there to
provide a service they don't absolutely
wrong Luke I disagree you're completely
wrong wrong excuse me the government
cares about you because if yeah if
you're not around right exactly exactly
California they really need you so they
they see you as like um you know a fresh
ripe Apple to be Juiced to just just
squeeze as much as they can and look I
got an apple tree do I care about the
apples well look I'm not gonna go save
the apples when they're injured rotting
or whatever I'm gonna throw them in the
garbage but I care about them in so far
as I would like to take the ones that
are good and use them for food and juice
is it the problem where you can't the
California doesn't want you to be able
to go take someone off the stream be
like you're sick come with me yeah
nothing like that oh my God can the
people there's no voluntarily come here
not when they're sick like that that's
very rare but it's it's you know look
the term we used to be able to keep
people for suicide homicide and Gravely
disabled Gravely disabled is essentially
gone and Grace what disables what is
what's going on what if uh what if we
did this what if we uh you know just put
lithium in the drinking water for
how our drinking water could help
prevent suicide put lithium in the water
and that's that's scary right yeah are
they really talking about it yes this is
vox.com this is mainstream
nbcfundedvox.com putting an article out
wow arguing that we should put lithium
in our drinking water to kind of
desensitize people this is because they
found that people who lived near water
sources that had lithium were much
happiness
they're like all right let's do it quote
unquote happier well I mean you knock on
the door and they're like hello yeah in
the right dose I think it would probably
be good for you I imagine it's the third
element I mean it's gotta have something
this is fluoridation all over again well
but this as is psychoactive yeah right
yeah and it's bad for your kids so like
top-down missions
what's your experience with top-down
medicine because I find like like saying
this is the vaccine everyone needs it
whereas everyone's different the
centralization of medicine is one of the
biggest catastrophes I've ever seen many
this one is best practice a highly
trained caring physician motivated
informed patient that is your most
efficient unit period anything else
screws it up and now you know in
medicine look I didn't realize 80 of
Physicians are employed now so when all
these Physicians froze in place and stop
treating patients I couldn't understand
what was happening well they got word
from on high from the centralized
Authority just sent him home and that
was it yeah it was a psychopath and
that's crazy and they didn't they didn't
even talk about early treatments they
didn't even talk about nothing
preventative treatment okay they were
told they were told they were instructed
to shut up don't do it well exactly so I
got sick and then um I felt fine and I
was like I just feel like I'm a little
sick then it got bad and I was like I'm
gonna call because maybe there's a
protocol for this that I'm not aware of
and you know I'm I'm somebody who reads
constantly but I was like maybe they'll
say like hey take this vitamin and do
this or otherwise I called the local uh
hospital and they went
go to sleep yeah and then I was like
monitor your po2 that's it and they were
like just go to sleep they didn't tell
me to do anything and then that night I
got really bad and I was shaking and so
I was like man if the if I got to call
Joe Rogan it's you know it's the only
thing I can do that's what I always
think when I get sick
but in all seriousness it was um I had
talked to a doctor and they said there's
nothing you can do but I knew from the
news not even from talking to Joe that
he had gotten monoclonal antibodies and
I said maybe maybe there's something he
knows by the way his treatment was like
a year into the pandemic we had that
stuff for six months before that right
it's easy now uh dude that to me is a
public health failure they should have
been educating people how to they want
to save lives educate people how to deal
with their this is the crazy thing so uh
we we all got sick we all got the
monoclonal antibodies and we were all
like just overnight just better it was a
weird experience and then I remember
um hearing from my doctor that they were
actually struggling to get more
monoclonal antibodies at a certain point
there was a moment right around the time
you probably got sick where they had
trouble Distributing it trouble getting
it troubling accessing it but they were
saying it was because the government was
shutting it down yeah they were they
were making it harder to get and then I
think what Biden said no to it or well
you know what it was how they destroyed
I think they started sending it into
areas of risk you know what I mean well
no Biden tried to take it away from
Florida and Florida and Amanda Santos
have to fight back saying no stopped
trying to take it away from us and then
they limited it because they said it was
quote ineffective which absolutely made
no sense at all and was not backed by
any side one of the things that I've
learned about public health is it's not
about medicine there many of them are
not even biologically trained certainly
not clinically trained it's about Equity
that is the new Public Health Mantra and
if and that was not the right it's an
important prism I get it's important but
it's not the whole story and it was not
useful or not important in terms of
getting through this particular pandemic
wasn't there somewhere there was people
in Texas denied antibodies because they
were the wrong color of skin they'd have
to Patient mind yeah which is absolutely
mind-boggling which is absolutely crazy
you take care of someone depending on
how much they need to be taken care of
not because of the way that they were
born
our skin color and this happened in the
United States there's a viral video of a
guy filming as the nurse is telling him
you don't qualify he's why not she's
like oh you're white
it's absolutely mindful no no I forgot
about this chapter it's interesting I'd
really forgotten about it but I remember
they were reallocating it and sending it
places where you couldn't get it but
that's that was the deal I had a patient
really get really sick with it now he
was it was probably Omicron and because
before we had Elmo current specific and
monoclonal so I wasn't that at the time
that upset about it but I thought man
it might have helped him because he got
really sick that's just yeah people not
a suit I mean that's a violation of the
Civil Rights Act people died because
they were specific criteria that he did
not meet just these criteria that was
has that changed the most important
criteria was the color of your skin it
was the same thing with the vaccine roll
out too remember I couldn't the reason I
got covered I couldn't get the vaccine
because I wasn't the right as that first
Equity role I remember that they started
yet yep marginalized people first right
and I couldn't get it and even though I
was treating covet at the time so and I
was going to go I was gonna go volunteer
my time in the ER they lost me because
and that's why it's important to point
out that the CEO of these big Pharma
companies are very good honorable people
because they chose not to get the
vaccine yeah because people couldn't
like the sacklers they're very honorable
the way they the way they told people
that uh what is it is it addictive uh
yeah I could go all day on the opioid
crisis
well you know we have baby 2098 in
California now where do actually have
their license taken away if they give
out misinformation
that says if any doctor is uh found to
be giving out misinformation that it
deviates from the standard of care their
their license could be what's the
standard that's the problem I've seen
standard of care when I when I first got
to the psychiatric I would start working
at Psychiatric Hospital in 1985 when I
first got there I acquired about two
dozen patients that were the subjects of
the standard of care in the late 40s and
50s somebody put an ice pick up above
their eye and swooped it back and forth
and they were disasters disasters and
that was the standard of care then I had
to live through the opioid standard of
care pain is the fifth Vital sign
remember that pain is what the patient
says it is pain control is what the
patient says it is they also started
Prosecuting Physicians for inadequate
treatment of pain so we all froze and we
we all froze and said everything to the
pain doctors the pain management guys
who felt that anybody that didn't use as
much opiates as possible as opiophobic
patients are in control let them decide
what they need and my patients are being
killed hand over fist what is Vicodin
that's opiate it is an opiate yeah
there's opiates and opioids they're just
the same thing yeah they're the same
thing yeah many people believe you know
your politicians could be bought off by
multinational corporations but many
people don't realize your doctors could
be bought off by multinational clubs
yeah but it's starting to Hiccup and
give us the business we got a warning oh
c you say error you said I'm seeing the
you said the I word
we were talking about an issue
pertaining to the CIA and the FBI and
politics and then there then the video
froze and then when you go back to watch
it that section is missing
so it's important that we talk about
people having putting F in the J look
look we've got we've got ultra high
speed business very expensive internet I
can see that our stream rate is is green
and perfect and people in the chat are
like FFF and the video's struggling
right now so don't I'm sorry if I don't
believe it's a coincidence that we're
having this conversation and all of a
sudden it's like believe nothing nothing
that's what I deal with all the time yep
uh yeah I don't assume anything I've
infected your guy let's talk about the
Civil War there's so much good Civil War
care we talk about that I know that's
what I'm saying let's get off this show
because I literally I'm like Harper
fairy's right here it's like Dr Drew do
you think there's a Civil War coming no
no you don't do not really why not
I just I don't see armies forming and I
I there could be some violence that
happens Army's forming though why do you
think armies would need to form I I mean
you're a civil unrest is not Civil War
you know I don't know maybe I made my
idea of civil wars it's based on America
yeah and when you look at other
countries Civil War uh Syria for
instance there weren't armies I mean you
had the uh the Syrian Army right but
that's the national Army you had I think
in the beginning of the Syrian uh
revolution in Civil War 12 disparate
factions of random people with random
weapons there's even a video of uh I
think it was it wasn't Isis it was
another terror terror well they say
terror group
um I'm not sure exactly which group it
was driving a truck from Detroit or
whatever they get their hands on
whatever they get their hands on and so
I think one of the mistakes a lot of
people make is they assume Civil War is
going to be like one you know faction of
states in their armies versus another
faction of states in their armies
because of an American perspective
you look at Spain and other countries
and it's like I mean we've got militant
far left extremists engaging in Terror
we've got right-wing militias lurking in
the shadows and training and biting
their time I just think we we if we have
50 independent states they are also
different one another people just will
vote with their feet they'll just move
but that's that is a precursor to to
civil conflict or civilized or War
movement Geographic hyperpolarization
so it's so I hear from a lot of people
one of the scariest things actually is
uh
people people started moving out of New
York with covet and all that stuff
people started moving for political
reasons we moved for political reasons
we were in South Jersey the riots
happened the riots crossed the bridge
and I went this is crazy Riders crossed
the bridge out of Philly into the
suburbs no I'm not interested in that so
we come out to the Tri-State you know
mostly West Virginia area and uh what
ends up happening is
Geographic hyper polarization will
result in staunch jurisdictions which
could result in A Confederacy and a
union type scenario you you need people
so you got New York City with like oh
it's you know California state 60
Democrat 30 Republican or something like
that
that actually keeps some stability but
it keeps skewing further and further
into into the left because people who
are the more you're leaving yeah and
then the state will become completely
dominated by one faction and that
already is it already is and right but
getting worse so then California allows
illegal immigrants to come to their
border but guess what there's no border
checkpoint between California and say
Nevada eventually one of these other
states is going to say we won't tolerate
this Arizona maybe and they'll put up a
border checkpoint and say California
won't do it well we're going to guard
from California and from our Southern
Border Kerry Lake talks about declaring
an invasion and sending the national
guard down to the southern border if she
wins uh the gubernatorial election
Carrie what are you going to do with
with the borders to the to the West
these other states are you going to put
up checkpoints and National Guard there
because if California lets them in
they'll come in there and they'll come
right through these are the kind of
things that I think will will lead to uh
the escalation and I think one of the
scariest things actually is we're in
this Calm before the storm
where you get people like Bill Burr
saying if you go outside and you talk to
people nobody's fighting anybody it's
just the internet and it's like yeah
that's like when people have hyper
polarized to the point where of course
Democrats aren't fighting Democrats in
New York they agree with each other of
course you know conservatives in the in
southern states aren't fighting each
other they agree with each other there
now you're seeing split via territory to
a more and more extreme degree and this
is not a new phenomenon there was a map
that was posted I think it may have been
by Matthew Iglesias I'm not entirely
sure a guy from Vox and it shows how
since the 80s
it was a map of partisanship by region
and this the the the country was mostly
white because it was 50 50 in most
places with some pink and some light
blue in certain areas that were somewhat
partisan and every election cycle you
can see areas getting darker red and
areas getting darker blue that's been
the 20 years of geographic
hyperpolarization so I'm not saying I
know for sure
um but I'm I'm certainly worried that
we're in that territory and that things
are getting worse I I worry that
something bad could happen I worry I'm
not clear what it takes to get out of
this I I
have faith in the better angels of our
nature but we'll see since we started
talking about Civil War YouTube's
connection has drastically improved
how's that weird no for real I'm sure I
see I was just let's test it out again
let's talk about the medical stuff right
now and talk about big Pharma robbing
and screwing everyone's health over I
don't trust big Pharma I've never
trusted big Pharma and I'm surprised
that uh all of the former leftists I
don't want you to call them these days
are now just in favor of big Pharma so
it's weird isn't it yeah it's very weird
not just a favor but but virtue signal
around them everything everything they
say is we did it just does saith the
Lord and attack non-believers yeah we
were ragging on that I could say we but
the country was ragged on pharmabro for
a long time yeah these pharmaceutical
companies are moving us off and now it's
like I don't think they understand on
what flimsy evidence everything was
pushed through yeah how extraordinary
the circumstance were and there was
extraordinary circumstance I understand
and if they were more clear like hey
it's a wartime kind of posture we're
we're gonna we're gonna have a it's a
fog of war in addition and we're not
quite sure what we're doing but we're
probably going to accept more problems
than we normally would we normally
wouldn't push stuff like this through
but we're trying to deal with a horrible
problem is there someone at YouTube with
their finger like they have they have a
throttle button yeah and they're like oh
they're donating
that's probably it that's probably just
AI but doctor it didn't change there's
now what eight Lab Rats that are behind
the the latest procedure that they're
trying to tell everyone they all got
covered yes
so there's eight lab brats that are
behind the latest study that are that
that is having the FDA pushing this
latest booster shot the so-called
bivalent booster has not been tested on
humans period only eight rats has it
been given to humans yeah now it has
been distributed it's between pushed
telling people to go get it and by the
rush I don't like the rush the more the
more serious problem is the fact that
this is CBS This is CBS yes yes right
here cbs17.com yeah they say it uh
should it matter they say well because
the reason the reason the justification
is this is how we develop our flu shots
this is how we test and develop flu
shots every year but that's a very very
different sort of platform just just
real quick this one's for you YouTube
all we're talking about is CBS a CBS
website that is News Guard certified
with a 92.5 out of 100 score saying they
say the basic fact is true the
preliminary findings presented by Pfizer
were based on tests in eight mice there
you go that's complete Insanity in my
opinion
so there is all this you know Dr Paul
offit one of the one of the major
proponents of the vaccine the MRNA
vaccine stuff and by the way above 75 I
am I'm vaccinating the hell out of my
patients and they're taking this one too
I'm giving because the benefits are
clear they've done great and packs of it
I'm using lots of packs of it in that
age group if you're over 75 years of old
of age the the consequences can kill you
and the treatments are working they're
preventing that they're preventing
serious illness they're preventing them
from dying this is what's going on in
the older age groups younger it gets
much less clear you brought up earlier
65 under for packs of it we don't know
what we're doing we really don't know
we're doing under 40 with the vaccines
we really don't know but Dr Paul offit
because of a signal that's coming out
that maybe there's some problems in
younger males particularly particularly
the modern vaccine he said you know I
don't think the younger males should
take this Omicron vaccine wolinski the
head of the CDC came out and said they
asked her they go you Paul off at your
guy he said don't do this and why why
are you saying 12 and above and she goes
she literally says this out loud into a
microphone on a national platform we're
just trying to simplify our messaging so
we're saying 12 and above to simplify
our messaging inside of there being a
possible problem with the vaccine in in
males so this was Paul off that you said
yep
how do I how do I look this one up good
luck on Google Dr Paul offit a young
male vaccine there there it is there it
is right there for kids under five he's
saying no five to eleven no need to
explain it better there it is down below
you were just there this one one more
right because we need to explain it
better yeah and I will stress this too
um you know Dr Drew that was the
original vaccine yeah obviously you are
literally Dr Drew but I would encourage
people if they're you know for whatever
their health issues are talk to your
doctor doctor and picture that's it yeah
yeah Dr Drew is not your doctor no I was
education this is a podcast no no no no
and and also I think it's important to
consider too that um generalities versus
uh specific issues so and I'm not saying
don't get the vaccine I'm saying I'm I'm
not by any means like I said I'm
recommending it strongly really pretty
how much all my patients over 65. it's
that when you get younger and you're
male make that decision with your doctor
it's a hard decision you got to make
that together I just my my point is I
think when it comes to the internet
stuff people might see a general claim
or a general thing it doesn't apply to
them and they might not realize it
unless they go and talk to it I mean you
said what was the quote they want to be
as general as POS no they said we need
to we need to simplify our messaging so
we're just saying 12 minutes
you need to get your fully bolster your
if you're over the age of 12.
not making simplified
doctor to be simplifying things to a
patient is kind of stupid like take it
between this problem if that's now the
standard of care and so if I talk to a
patient go hey look there's here's the
signal we're concerned and 17 year olds
we're seeing this now I've violated the
standard of care I have to lose myself
if you're looking for the video I just
retweeted it on my Twitter account yeah
that she was up on top of the page here
it's I mean if anything this is exposing
that we have been that our system of
medicine in the in the world is very
chaotic Public Health let me let me read
what pointer says pointer says wolensky
told jansing we are simplifying our
message the message is you need to get
your fall booster vaccine so go ahead
and get it if you're over the age of 12.
if you've received your primary series
if you're more than two months out of
your last shot you can get an updated
vaccine and so we've intentionally
simplified the message so it's very very
clear it's also very clear that those
who are over the age of 50 even over the
age of 60 or 70 are more at risk for
severe disease through hospitalization
and death and it is especially important
that people in that demographic and
others who are at high risk of severe
disease get that updated she made tons
of sense in the latter half of that
statement when I was listening to it
when it happened I thought it was so
weird the beginning part of it was like
what are you saying yeah and the latter
part was like okay yeah that's right
foreign
that's not my doctor why why don't they
just tell you to please go and consult
with your physician
I have no idea so so uh Casey neistat
he's a cool dude I'm a big fan of his he
tweeted something like go get vaccinated
and then I responded with go and talk to
your doctor first or something like that
and then he said something to me like
funny I didn't go to a doctor I just
went to uh Pharmacy no a drive-through
stuck my arm out the window and they
gave me the vaccine and then I was like
that person doesn't know your history
they don't they don't have a
relationship with you it's just a random
person like to me that seems
irresponsible you should go to your
doctor but here's the crazy thing the
response I got from all of these these
people were like I was being an
anti-vaxxer for telling people telling
people go go to a doctor and ask about
the vaccine that was considered
anti-vaxx and I was like I don't I don't
understand like and it goes and they're
a Trumper except you're not a Trumper
because it's his vaccine so well it's
very strange they respond they respond
to me but Tim the doctor would just say
get the vaccine and I'm like then what's
the problem here's my thing here's my
thing if if you go to somebody who's not
your doctor and ask them for medication
I think you're you're in trouble Joe
Rogan and but I mean Joe Rogan's advice
was call a doctor no you know what I
mean of course if you if you go to
someone who's not your doctor
who is like a a pharmacist attack or
something to get a medication and they
don't know your history my concern with
all of this was that
oh we're getting the error again my
concern my concern was that work there
are adverse effects for all medications
all medications anytime you interact
with the medical system there's always
potential for trouble and so when you go
to your doctor they ask you for your
allergies and things like that yeah if
you go to a stranger and they don't know
you and you sit down in front of a
7-Eleven I mean what if you have an egg
allergy which was one of the
contraindications or whatever I think
it's really important that people just
do like hey this is a really important
thing that's going with this pandemic
you should talk to your doctor because
what I don't want to see is people who
could have avoided Adverse Events
being subject to these Adverse Events
and then conspiracy theorists being like
Ah that's proof and it's like no no no
you go to your doctor minimize risk
maximize your benefit your doctor knows
your medical history better than anybody
else and can fully inform you for your
particular circumstance so you do a
truly informed consent on the care as
opposed to mandated streamlined you know
sort of recommendations it's kind of
they're hitting us again it's it's as if
it's kind of being treated where there's
no public sanitation because like the
Spanish flu I think they were afraid it
was going to be something like that but
they didn't have like running water and
soap a lot of people didn't I mean a lot
of people did but if we didn't have
running water and covet hit it probably
would have killed a huge segment like
half the popular you know it could have
without running water
now this is actually a good point I
think what people don't realize too is
when the when the pandemic first hit a
lot of people myself included we were
like hey maybe we got to take this
seriously this is getting freaky we are
looking what's happening in China and
stuff and maybe it would have been
100 years ago when we didn't have the
same degree of Sanitation and access to
uh refrigerators and and clean running
water and things like that it probably
would have been substantially worse oh
yeah coveted was nasty it was nasty to
me you know where say terms like social
distancing came from and six feet
distancing made up at a whole cloth
completely completely made up by the NIH
completely by who NIH uh yeah there was
a guy named Paul Alexander was at the
table and he was like why six feet he
goes ah that sounds right
and you will not see the term social
distancing in any infectious Tech book
in publication it doesn't exist and then
six feet is just completely made up at a
whole cloth yeah and the um all these
things lockdown that was all made up too
that's never been advocated before in in
human history the plexiglasting totally
made up as well no science behind
literally a bad idea didn't get anywhere
else yes and it also made sure that the
germs were all building up on one
particular wall and platform and staying
there and and as you said they you're
getting me riled up because you're
bringing up all the things that I
remember are just coming back in the
back of my mind and I'm ready just to
tell you it needs a postmortem I'm
trying to interview all the people and
put it all together so that's what I'm
doing on Wednesdays at three o'clock for
Eastern Pacific I do want to talk about
censorship because we've had this this
story you're being censored right now
just because I'm talking about Medicine
by a physician with doubly board
certified two fellowships and I'm I'm
being sanser for just discussing the
facts maybe we don't know for sure it's
just where it happens to me all the time
I I gotta say that there's a there's
very few circumstances where for some
reason it's not it's on YouTube's end
okay so for those are just tuning in
we're we're getting weird hiccups on the
show and um we have uh high speed
gigabit fiber connection I can I we
track our own network we've got it it's
robust it's professional it's not on our
end on YouTube's end something must be
going wrong forgive me if I don't think
this is just coincidence and it
correlates with us talking about these
particular topics we like switched to
Civil War and then it I'm not kidding uh
it says excellent connection and then a
yellow a yellow bar up here saying error
YouTube is not receiving enough
information that's the that's fifth
generational Warfare if it's really
happening which might be I worked in
social media Administration sometimes
stuff goes wrong people think it's
coincidence yeah yeah it can often times
be technical glitches but you know
that's what fifth generational Warfare
is is psychological warfare when you
don't know what's happening Alex
Barrington got another uh opinion from a
judge oh this is huge we got to pull
this up to this point it's a fifth
circuit the Court of Appeals yeah the
the floodgates have been open my friends
let me pull up his Twitter account
all right let's see there it is is this
one this one's at right so here we go
ladies and gentlemen this is huge news
Alex Berenson he's a journalist says
boom I say again boom the federal fifth
Circuit Court appeals just said Twitter
and other social media platforms don't
have an unlimited right to discriminate
against speech let a thousand flowers
bloom hi and there's an opinion I hope
James O'Keefe is listening somewhere off
the distance and
um gearing up for war
here we go it says the first amendment
protects speech It generally prevents
the government from interfering with
people's speech or forcing them to speak
the platforms argue that because they
are host and transmit speech the First
Amendment also gives them an unqualified
license to invalidate laws that hinder
them from censoring speech they don't
like and they say that license entitles
them to pre-inforcement facial relief
against hb20 we reject the platform's
attempts to extract a free willing
censorship right from the Constitution's
Free Speech guarantee the platforms are
not newspapers their censorship is not
speech they're not entitled to
pre-inforcement facial relief is it
fascial is it facial and hb20 is
constitutional because it neither
compels nor obstructs the platform's own
speech in any way The District Court
aired in concluding otherwise and abused
its discretion by issuing a preliminary
injunction the preliminary injunction is
vacated and this case is remanded for
further proceedings consistent with its
opinion
the floodgates have been opened not to
mention not to mention we've seen uh
numerous reports now that the federal
government has been colluding with big
Tech to censor so particularly when it
came to fauci Luke you mentioned this
they went after a fouchy parody account
they were like can we get this one taken
down it's not one of our something like
that the government went after Alex
Berenson the White House I believe it
was the White House contacted Twitter
and said why haven't you banned him yet
yes correct so now he won that case he
won it well he didn't win the case he
got he got uh settlement settlement and
he got the disclosure he got the uh what
do they call it when they could you can
find all of that Discovery you got
Discovery and that's where they found
this communication and uh now he's won
another major victory here so uh this is
fantastic he told me it's just the
beginning he's going to continue well
good I'm glad to see it yeah um maybe
maybe we need a concerted effort maybe
we need to figure out how we can um I
mean anybody who's been impacted by this
needs to file suit I think we've got a
class action already there are a bunch
of Physicians doing class action against
Facebook oh that's and that one's really
important especially yeah because they
ruined people's career they really
destroyed people why because fear the
public health authorities in this
country decided they needed to use fear
to follow a zero covet policy and they
believed their Chinese Associates and
professional colleagues that the
lockdown was the only way to do that
that was the first time with this
country at West had ever thought about
locking that it was the Chinese
Communist Party policy I will I will say
this uh as well right now with this
statement here from Alex Berenson uh I
am going to have our lawyers sitting
ready and waiting in case they stand for
tonight uh or or otherwise I mean it is
it is absolutely insane that these
companies think they are immune and and
I've argued this a million times now
that we know there's been direct
collusion I'd be willing to I'd be
willing to bet we can find the same
collusion between Google and the
government that we found between Twitter
and the government and Facebook Mark
Zuckerberg's admission you think
YouTube's cleaning this one I doubt it
absolutely why why are they focused on
search so you so YouTube can back off
and let conversations in the public
sphere happen
or they can face Discovery and be
included in this wave which will
ultimately create a Cascade of negative
impacts on their platform mainline
Medical Doctors were censored their
voice was taken away from the commons
because they dared to show data and
science that didn't go along with the
narrative and paradigms they wanted
people to go along so seeing this news
it emboldens me it shows me you know
what take me down censor me because we
could fight this in a court of law and I
will if anything happens to me from now
on let's go I now have a little
relationship with YouTube and they very
kindly reinstated so you can get
reinstated not just yourself but there's
other doctors the AI that's the problem
but they need to adjust that yeah it's
not it's not just that it's not just
that there's other doctors we can't even
mention their names here that you
interviewed that aren't that don't have
a relationship that haven't gotten their
Channel back so so it's not just this is
the issue with rulings like this what
will happen is I assure you that when
this when this he posted this four hours
ago I'm willing to bet that a legal team
game that's working with YouTube or
whatever immediately said we need to
have a meeting right now and I would
imagine part of their advice to YouTube
was
if you do cross that line you could so
I'll we'll put in simple math terms
if you think someone's saying a bad
thing on your platform will cause you
let's say one degree of damage
so you make a move against that to
rectify that one degree of damage you
could then be on the hook for 10 times
as much damage if you censor someone
because you don't like what they've said
and they sue you it may it might open
the floodgates to eliminate all of your
protections so you need to pull back
this is what often happens they'll say
don't fight this battle because it'll
make things worse an example is when it
was what was it Mississippi had that the
abortion law was that Mississippi and
then that so this group was like we're
gonna Sue to stop this and then the
Supreme Court basically wipes out Roe v
Wade this is one of the big issues with
getting involved in a legal battle you
can make it worse for yourself when you
lose or you can strategically Retreat
and pull back this makes me think that
Twitter apparently corporations think
they have free speech a corporation an
entity an invisible entity thinks it has
free speech on the U.S Constitution
maybe it does technically but Mega Corps
are different beasts and social media is
like the phone company it's not it
doesn't
choosing who to shut down is not a form
of free speech if you come maybe if it's
you come into my house and you're saying
something I don't want you to say I
control the land I can I have my free
speech overrides yours I guess that's
the way it works legally but for a
corporation no I think Time's A Change
company I'll tell you I'll tell you what
if YouTube says if if the rules were
this if you violate our policies we will
remove you from the partner program I
would say fair enough
yeah it it is there's I don't believe
there's an obligation for YouTube to
sell on my behalf advertising but to
restrict people's access to your content
like we we've been dealing this with now
for the past couple weeks probably
because more than two months of the
election our thumbnails don't load when
we launch the live stream for this show
right now that you're watching many of
you might notice on the home page of
YouTube even if you do see it it's a
gray block and then Ian will be like Tim
the thumbnail sign up and I'm like and I
have to go in every night every night
and and and the issue is we can see that
that has a direct impact on viewers
because people scrolling their homepage
won't see the thumbnail and they just
won't out of sight out of mind we also
several times in this show got a weird
YouTube error when we talked about
certain things that literally happens
so you know look they play these dirty
games they've been playing them with us
for a while now and
it is it is insane to me that YouTube is
basically supposed to be like a common
carry it's supposed to be like a phone
company it's supposed to be a platform
but it said they act like a newspaper
they have editorial rules they say
here's our editorial rules you have to
abide by sometimes they don't even tell
you the rules there was an instance
where there was a guy we call Voldemort
if you said his name they would delete
your video outright even though it was
never posted in their rules that was the
case right well I've gone back several
times and asked what the rules are they
won't tell you right yeah they have some
rules listed I know uh one guy I'm not
going to say his name because I don't
want to come I don't want them coming
after his new show but with no strikes
no rule breaks they deleted his entire
channel 300 and something thousand
subscribers you know they did tell us
that they were having sort of they were
under sort of a multinational attack
right now with a lot of misinformation
which kind of interesting to me that
somebody's trying to already stir things
up as the election goes in and to some
extent I I kind of you know I want them
not to be allowing stuff that's designed
to harm us right right but they have
found that certain topics are in but
just really quick I think there's no
rules because they want you to be
paranoid they want you to censor
yourself they want you to be scared to
even dare mission accomplish something
that that could go against the the grain
or the establishment and I think it's
about the same yeah 2098 I could lose my
license I'm scared [ __ ] and it's and and
let it out Drew it's a lot more Sinister
than than just like hey let's let's try
to you know keep the rules here because
you look at what the what Facebook was
doing with the FBI Facebook was was
colluding with them giving them
information spying on people getting
people's private messages but they also
did that with covet there's Facebook
emails showing how Zuckerberg was
offering Dr fauci data on users to help
the lockdown policies to help people
make sure that they weren't going
outside of their homes Facebook was
volunteering that information so though
the way that they work together the way
that they collude is far more
interconnected than we even know about I
think if we're going to avoid a Civil
War uh it's by giving people control
their social media networks and their
monitors their money I know they're
trying to turn ethereum into the new
Global Currency right now it's just
really ethereum that's what it's pretty
much they're like oh they just took they
took ethereum off of proof of work
meaning the miners that were making it
it's no longer that now it's proof of
stake as like two days ago so whoever
has the ethereum is going to control the
ethereum network basically they created
Fiat they just created another digital
Fiat and it looks like they're going to
try and make that the Global Currency
ethereum and make who's that ethereum uh
who is doing it probably the American
government the world economic Forum the
Chinese government
you know those are probably the three
biggest movers on the planet many other
corporations you're familiar with the
great research see a book right there
about it yeah
you'll be happy what you will own
nothing and you will yeah I'm sorry
that's the quote but it's actually you
will own nothing you will have no
privacy and you will be happy yeah the
actual quote was from a tweet it the
year is was it twenty Thirty Thirty
twenty Thirty I own nothing I have no
privacy and I've never been happier it
was an article in a policy paper that
they were pushing for their vision of
what's going to be happening in the
future which goes along the same
principles of the UN 2030 Vision I just
want I want to point out too that um to
a certain degree owning less stuff will
actually make you happy they say that
when you own stuff your stuff owns you
but this what we're getting from their
vision of it is not exactly what is
meant by owning nothing owning nothing
is like having your necessities and then
foregoing the ridiculous quest for
material Goods like luxuries but their
vision is more like you're going to eat
a bag of crickets and live in a pot I
think they want to strip property rights
away from people and that's like the
basis of this country basically that's
and that's the basis of Communism and
that you won't be able to escape and you
won't be able to have a car and you
won't be able to transport anymore it's
the worst thing you know like back in
the day if like things got bad you could
be like well I guess I'll go Exile
myself and live in the woods or whatever
or just go off somewhere else there's
nowhere to go anymore they track you
everywhere it's by Design well I don't
know if it's everywhere but that's what
they I mean you guys are totally
depressing me yeah I'm stressed about
this because I feel like we're about to
evolve from the liberal economic order
which we've had since 1946 where it's
american-led rules-based economy
military bases to a New World Order
which is like this new global
technocratic governance where they're
trying to spy on people and make sure
they're not stepping out of line because
they don't want people to go crazy they
don't want people to blow things up they
don't want Hitler to come again I get it
I get the the purpose may be seem like
benevolent but stripping people of their
property rights isn't going to go well
in the United States
and we need to work together with you
Klaus and you know that to make a better
world I I think decentralized property
ownership is key man can Ian you know
when I when I go out to chicken City and
they're barking at me do you think I
care
no but Margaret escaped not at all but
we're not chickens and and rules
Margaret escaped she she was where'd she
go so we have uh I see a chicken City
and then we have a green plastic fence
around it so the chickens can come out
and graze in the fresh grass and
Margaret is clever and finds a way she
finds areas to slip through because
there's more bugs and fresh berries and
things like that outside of the grass
Grays she brought the Frizzle with her
this time
and we don't like that because we want
to control this and they balk at me
because they want to come out I don't
care what they're saying so look when
you say Klaus we got to work together
he's looking at you like you're some
dumb chicken maybe but he's obviously
looking at me like I have good taste in
blood
um I love how he's ripped off my
freaking font almost not the font not
the [ __ ] so what's happening is it's the
battle between Order and Chaos the the
Klaus and his buddies they want order
they want world order this is a new
world order they don't like chaos I get
it but you need a balance in order You
could argue is a little bit better than
chaos but you need a balance of the two
you cannot have one without the other
it's order out of chaos which is
essentially their their guiding
principles but doctor bro Drew I wanted
to come back to what you said you're
saying you're getting depressed I think
you're getting you know depressed and
sad about this is all a part of the
conditioning all a part of the plan and
I think they win if you are like this we
are here I showed up yeah we're
presented with a lot of challenges we're
presented with a lot of opportunities as
well so in the face of all the adversity
we could either make ourselves better or
we could bow down and let them win and I
think this has given us an incredible
opportunity to challenge ourselves test
ourselves and to really try to be the
best version just walking around here I
went running today at the what's the
city
Brunswick Brunswick Brunswick the trail
did you go on the trail though by the
river or went down by the river and
stuff and I ran ran ran ran ran and I I
feel like I can fill my lungs here
people are happy there's some there's a
history attached to everything the
lockdowns are particularly weak when we
were here it was like they were kind of
there but everyone just was like you go
to California just you feel terrible
yeah I got the brake dust yeah
apparently the brake dust is so small
particularly that it goes through the
alveoli in your
like it's not as much the smog as it is
the break does apparently right I don't
know much about it well yeah I would
happily think the brake dust of our if
our governor would be a rational person
you know it start to help us keep the
people that are dying on our streets
every day and not encumber our licenses
for crazy things and all these just
crazy things we're doing you think
California's too big I kind of see it
being split in half maybe North and
South is two different states I don't
know I gotta I gotta read page 43 of
Ian's book yeah bring it up this is
riding in the dark by Ian Crossland it's
funny it's funny how Fire Burns straight
up what is it electrons dissembled
dissembled carbon that's what it says or
whatever is producing the flame it's
reddish yellow blue white red like the
American flag Stars and Stripes look
like a burning fire anyway it burns away
from the center not necessarily lighter
than air though it may be it burns up
away from the center of the suck sucked
up away from like anti-gravity what is
it escaping from pressure I have a
feeling if you created a system a
pressure system where there is a
pressurized fire and a low pressure side
it may burn sideways though it may still
burn away from the Earth's core too many
assumptions without experimentation
it's it's I got to tell you man it's
just like it sounds like you were stoned
and just writing stuff you were thinking
about 20 years man no I know I know this
wasn't a very low point in my life
I I am I am literally uh encouraging
that because it's a fascinating ex like
it's a fascinating thing to think about
yeah wrote it as a joke I just was bored
and depressed we were starting mine so I
was like I had some Vision in my life
but at the same time I was totally
disenfranchised with the world like with
the with the Federal Reserve I've
learned about the military industrial
complex I felt lost I felt like what you
mentioned earlier I'm feeling right now
yeah like well no I love it because like
you can read what fire is you know I
mean you can Google it and look at that
instead of it
I would drink because I wanted to be
like view casket I'm like that's not a
good reason to start drinking yeah you
didn't beat women did you no I never did
that was
alcohol shrinks your brain so we're on
the we're on the precipice of it of a
rebel a global I roll the 76. what I
rolled a seven yeah what did you roll
earlier by the way uh I think it was hit
though
like the opposite of yours yeah 76 or
1776 from each other yeah weird uh I
something is about to change I mean the
US is kind of based on chaos like it was
a revolution it kind of is still a
revolute like it's a constant Revolution
against its own government to to keep it
unstable so that it never becomes an
overarching you know monolith yet it's
managed to be so yeah and it still
consists and so now we're gonna be up
against Global powers that want to
create massive amounts of social order
and we need to maintain this benevolent
chaos to allow great laws to come out of
of the crappy order you know a bad loss
what you're saying though is that this
may be something we're passing through
the ball and that maybe some good will
come out then we'll find a new
equilibrium which is what my hope is
yeah it's a process yeah I do I like
people I want to believe everyone's the
same everyone's awesome everyone's a god
everyone's a leader but like no yeah
it's the truth is I think they're a
better man and then there's the plebs
and I hate that I
well I mean there are plenty of people
that have unfulfilled potential that's
for sure and I would love to see
everyone fulfill their potential how
about that
you ever see that video of the Iraqis in
afghanis trying to do jumping jacks no
oh man let me pull it up oh yeah yeah
you know it's uh it's sad because it
feels like uh wasted potential
and uh is this one it this is this is a
black pill oh yeah
look at this guy right here yeah like
what's he doing
they're not called jumping jacks what
are they called best
you can't call them jumping jacks well I
knew what you called them there's a
specific thing we had a military guy and
explained what they're what they're like
they're called something more specific I
guess I think those might be jumping
jacks actually look at this guy yeah
he's the best what's he doing wow a star
jump no it's not a star well but a side
straddle hop you know that's a kind of a
side straddle side straddle hop yeah
people get older their ability to
reproduce motor actions and stuff it's
like trying to learn a dance or
something it's like um is that what it
is but but you know I watched that video
and I'm just kind of like these the
weighted potential there's so many
people there's a myth off of his you
know what there's a myth of the Native
Americans when the con when the
conquisters were coming in on the boats
they were out there in the ocean and
they would go out and they'd look and
they would never see boats because they
didn't know what a boat was clouds it
was clouds they said they saw big
mountains and clouds so because that's
what they knew it was real so that's
what they saw and it was only eventually
that one of the shaman was like actually
there's something there that I don't
understand but I see and so it takes the
brain if it doesn't know something
exists
a great deal of effort to ex to perceive
it yeah and maybe that's the same thing
with realizing potential because they
they don't know that they have it that's
interesting I like that yeah Forrest
says side straddle hop is what it's
called
I just I just feel like so much of
humanity is wasted potential
you know I I hate that they they call
what was that guy called him useless
eaters Yuri uh are you sure you've all
know Harari he really did and he wasn't
like mean about it he's just saying you
know utilitarianly there are a class of
useless eaters that just and they don't
need to be though he's got sapiens all
of those people could be engineers and
scientists and researchers and writers
and singers and artists but the
potential is lost well he's arguing
because of the latest technological
advancements this is going to create a
elitist group of people that are going
to live like gods and there's going to
be a lot of useless people that need to
be positive
he literally said he needs to be
pacified with drugs and video games he
hangs out with uh Russell Brand for some
reason Russell Brand is seen giving him
a kiss but he's known as Klaus schrob's
right-hand man really yep
you're well Russell Brand is a sleeper I
don't know
he's seen kissing it's important that we
realize they're not our enemies people
they're just want something that we have
maybe disagree with the method but
they're they're also human and they want
they understand the world is huge and I
don't chaotic and we need to create a
new kind of global Community yeah but
but there was that one video from Klaus
Schwab where he was like I just don't
like Ian Crossland yeah she ripped me
off I'm coming to have a conversation
with you brother he's like sitting there
reading your book and he's like I must
wipe out Humanity
we'll figure something out we need more
fun in the world
that's funny right I want to make a song
with Klaus Schwab uh I tell you what's
happening I tell you what's fun uh just
watch do you watch yes do you watch The
Fast and Furious movies no why not so
um in the first fast and the furious
it's like a cop undercover cop yeah and
that's it
okay at Fast and Furious nine they go to
outer space
tell me that is not the the coolest
thing ever it's just like they're
they're they've made the weirdest series
and I am so ready for final Fast and
Furious 10 where they're they're either
in Transformers Megazords or they get
super powers see that's a more positive
thing we can talk about right Vin Diesel
flying around like Superman that'd be
awesome
well we can go back to talk about the
end of the world uh Cloud Schwab is
gonna kill Ian or something so let's
talk about my uh superhero experience
out in the desert where I train with
special options oh yes what was that
yeah that's uh forces so yeah I went
with a bunch of people out to the Des a
bunch of celebrities like Mel B and
Jamie Lee Spears you know people who
turned out to be very very tough Jamie
and Lynn Spears yes and uh she did
really well a bunch of professional
athletes too and they did better guess
what and uh yeah we went out to the Wadi
Rum desert which where they filmed Star
Wars and dune and all that stuff was 120
degrees and and we they just it was just
on that we just were 24 7 in Ops Force
training it was incredible how old are
you 64. you're 64. wow you don't look
64. and I I'm not sure they should have
people my age out in those those
conditions anymore because uh you have
to see what happens tonight oh boy but
but uh I mean how would you do how do
you feel you did what did you do and how
do you you you're off base all the time
you never know what you're supposed to
be doing they always punish you and if
you get anything wrong they punish the
whole group and the punishments push-ups
and crab walking and into the dunk tank
and into the mud oh my God and it is
and then you know we jumped out of a
helicopter you know backwards and yeah
but the funny thing is like a TV show
right yeah so like you literally could
have just been like I ain't doing it you
could stop at any time yeah you could
stop anytime and you could also opt out
of anything but people felt I don't know
they yeah you get hypnotized by the
staff it's really kind of hypnotic State
you're in really you get so they start I
the look they come at you from the
beginning like in your face and within
about six hours you're wanting to do
what they're telling you to do it's very
strange and they they really emphasize
just trust them and do what we're
telling you I think we should do it we
should have Ian do basic training yeah
okay yeah three months well just because
Oh you mean like run the basic training
no that's what you meant like no do
basic training who care no I think I
think you might be right I do need more
order in my life I just don't want it
forced on me I never really like because
I don't like nonsensical order when
people like do it to do it I don't like
that kind of we should have Ian do
Soldier fit yeah we could bring could
you imagine if it entertains and
inspires people at this point because I
think what we're talking about is
creating a new world order literally but
what we need to do is inspire people to
govern themselves and to take control
and if we can be that in uh example then
12 year olds that are listening to this
show yes are going to remember in 20
years and be personally responsible and
be healthy and be happy and be
prosperous individuals and think about
this if we I think if we do Soldier fit
and have a soldier fit come down and enu
did it in the mornings yeah then it's
like what three months Ian's gonna be
ripped I'll do it with you yeah I was
thinking about doing that today oh
gladly yeah I'm bringing another trainer
don't worry it'll just be a quick snip
but you don't have to but but I'm
bringing another trainer here and you're
welcome to join me I'm going to be doing
this
imagine Ian ripped pumped full of
testosterone talking about DMT he's
gonna be like you got to do it yeah I
need to get people to take me seriously
man
that's one way to do it is to get strong
I mean it shows that you're dedicated
and that speaks without words discipline
yeah yeah I think you should just hold
your foot yeah I mean you know we we
um I'm out skating every day half the
crew is out skating and and you know
it's it's keeping us fit we're doing a
big trip tomorrow Ian you got to get you
got to get basic training you got 20
push-ups earlier I've been looking at
myself on the cast castle and I'm like
God I look so skinny in my posture and
that is forward hey my staff is freaking
out because you're apparently your
website is sending everybody to an old
TV show I did 14 years ago called life
changer as opposed to my YouTube channel
which is where we're trying to send
everybody yes your dear wife okay okay I
had Dave fix it for us we should thank
you
but Dr Drew if I could ask you yeah
you've been in the public like for a
while especially in the medical field
what do you think is one of the biggest
misconceptions or like misnomers or
things people usually get wrong when it
comes to you know medicine or personal
health that that that you always see as
a continuing Trend well
oh my God there's so many things yeah
um
one thing that I've been harping on like
crazy and this is not pertinent for
everybody but it's pertinent for all the
homeless people and it's burden for all
the crazy drug policies we have had
there which is that addiction substance
use disorder is a progressive illness it
ends in death so even if you have a
heroin injection site where the nurses
are administering the heroin those
people will still progress and they will
have more increased brain problems
behavioral problems medical problems and
they will die so this is the part that
everybody keeps missing meth ends in
death opiates end in death and that's it
period no matter how they're getting the
drug now you may be able to sort of
change the course a little bit or the
timing difference but overall it's a
it's a progressive illness and that's
that's one piece that drives me crazy uh
there's other things that I I think
people are unrealistic about even I was
I gotta say I remember I was getting a
physical one time and it was like the
third time I'd come in my blood pressure
was a little high and I'm like I don't
know I'm gonna run some more I'm gonna
get out there run a little longer I'm
gonna watch my weight and she goes this
woman physician leaned into me and she
goes you can only unrend it you can only
outrun your genetics so long and I
thought oh my God she's so right I need
to take a medication and and that there
are things as you age that you just have
to stay ahead of and we we can extend
our life abnormally with Medical
Treatments stem cells I I I'm not
talking about stem cells those are
anti-inflammatory I'm talking about me
taking two antihypertensives I'm talking
about taking a cholesterol medication
that kind of stuff once I once I sort of
got out of my denial we talked a little
bit about this before the show what do
you think about NAD you know I love it
oh I take nicotine no I take nicotine
and riboside every day for those that
aren't familiar NAD therapy like IV
Therapy it's uh nicotine was it
nicotinamide at a 99 it's hitting the
oxidative state of the cells and it may
affect aging may affect a lot of things
I don't know what you're doing you know
how often you do it and then how good
that is we have no clinical data on that
but the biology looks very good and we
do use it in Alcoholics and early
recovery and it does help them um yeah
so calming Mexico since since we got
covid uh you know Joe Rogan talks about
doing NAD quite often we've we've done
it uh regularly and not nearly as
regularly as say someone like Joe does
but we get it you know frequently and
all of my vitals have dramatically
improved there's something to it is
there a downside is there a risk as you
know risk reward is always the thing by
the way this is something that risk
reward analysis was something completely
abandoned during covet strangely enough
but risk reward is about medicine and
there's a lot of things that look good
that may have a downside so I always
worry about until we have enough data
enough experience I always worry about
the potential risks they say that it
triggers like cellular regeneration is
is that maybe the case well I think what
he does is it it creates the sirtuins it
helps grow sirtuins I think it does what
is it three three and five but I know
the holster two one story is is part of
the story which might help with the
Aging yeah the sirtuins measure the
energy in the mitochondria so when the
cell divides if they make sure there's
enough so that the cells don't have to
clip off the end caps of the of the
chromosomes telomeres and so they don't
age we think we think I mean again these
are very complicated so you're saying
that if I keep getting an ID I'll live
forever we'll see we'll see I heard it I
will you won't I heard if you have
cancer you should avoid it because it
goes to your cancer cells and builds
them also it could be so so there's a
lot of different prostate cancer you
know I have a cancer patient I prostate
out 12 years ago and what about Tito for
cancer patients have you us looks
there's some data looks good but you but
again you're you're this is all around
the margins you know we have things we
have treatments we have data we know
what we're doing with certain stuff
there are things that you can do maybe
to help things out and I remember when
uh um like I had my process moved that
and I didn't want that that surgeon to
be giving me any keto nutrition advice I
wanted to take out the effing prostate
without affecting the pudendal nerve for
the penis that was important to me it's
very important and I sat down and said
how many of these you've done he goes
1100 how many complications there's a
lot of complications of these up you get
zero I said let's go do you do
meditation a little bit I have you
looking at the placebo effect do I
believe in the placebo yeah they say
that I've heard that it's like effective
and they don't really know I I did years
and years of psychotherapy a certain
kind of psychotherapy in in that
psychotherapy
I was in in a very deep state with this
therapist like it was like very
emotionally focused therapy and so those
kinds of deep interpersonal states are
extremely renewing to me so I feel like
I'd be a good like uh hypnosis candidate
yeah if you ever had the power and
influence of like a Bill Gates or Dr
fauci what kind of policies would you
push forward for them and decentralize
everything there you go
I would I would create Pathways and
advice and when this whole all this
centralization and control started
happening when I was probably in the
early 2000s late 90s I was you know I
was really deep in my career when I was
working 18 hours a day I was doing all
half Psychiatry half the day and then
addiction regular medicine the rest of
the day and um and I just kept saying if
I am such a crappy physician that I need
all this oversight and regulation send
me back for more training I love my
training it's great I love training I
don't I just want this clerks telling me
what to do this insurance salesman I did
this is ridiculous or some some
regulator in Washington determining how
I take care of my patients which is
complicated have you ever smoked DMT no
but I had like the trippy question all
right well I'm watching all that very
very carefully I've talked to him
forgetting the name of the guy that was
the founder of maps
multi-disciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies so I I am very
interested in how psychedelics you're
going to be used fortunate acronym
Rick Dublin and it's going to be useful
it's going to be something but there is
a downside there too so please people
don't run ahead of the size we're
talking about the downside that you
actually meet demons and they'll try to
steal your soul or well it depends what
you're talking about there's acid
there's mushrooms there's different
psychedelics different effects the
demons
your esophagus no yeah hey hey yeah we
all know that's called a purge that I
know that I know doesn't happen they
feel like it's happening but that
doesn't happen
um but I had a terrible reaction to
cannabis horrible and I'll never touch
it what was the reaction I developed
something called a anticholinergic
delirium ooh when when that sounds
unfortunate I was at a party with a very
famous uh person that loves weed and he
was out there and I was talking it was
not soup
with him and there was another guy there
who was even more famous for weed and I
thought I'm gonna have to smoke with
these guys and they of course handed to
me took a big hit and I immediately
couldn't feel my hands on my feet I got
agitated I I couldn't see and I had to
go outside and it was the most
uncomfortable miserable feeling in my
entire how long did it last that was
about four hours that was an overdose uh
but it was but the syndrome was
anticholinergic I had photophobia I had
dry mouth I had all the usual hellions
yeah that's what you get from taking a
whole Fistful of Benadryl but I think
and I had only Misery the thing about
this is getting high is an overdose
that's the problem with the stuff and
people don't I think most of society
thinks that's the the purpose of it but
a tiny bit where you don't even know
what's in you I had one hit it's a lot
it that that's just those guys those
guys were going nuts on these cigars
these blunts they were smoking addicts
they were like really going at it I
thought oh how bad can it be I'll try it
and then I just all of a sudden couldn't
walk I was like parkinsonian I was like
I was I was like
um I couldn't move around well I
couldn't sit down
careful with your brain everybody that's
the bottom line yeah Yes actually the
reality is that drugs are just drugs and
if they're used properly they can be
life-saving sometimes and that includes
even what people consider to be
recreational I think they're doing like
PTSD treatments with what like MDMA or
something mushrooms well that was
Goblin's big study in in the right hand
it feels that MDMA a well-trained
therapeutic setting MDMA clearly works I
asked you about contradiction as well a
lot of people who have a hard time
quitting heroin or smoking cigarettes
usually turn to different forms of
psychedelics there's ibogaine there's
mushrooms so ibogaine Ayahuasca this
stuff I I've been seeing my patients you
know over the years try that stuff and
there's I've seen out of probably a
hundred cases of people trying to stop
usually opiates that's usually what
they're trying to stop
um one time they stayed stop the other
all the other ones stay stopped for six
months and then went back with ibogaine
usage and then some of them had like
persistent personality changes from the
Evergreen too which was really scary to
me it's like it's one thing to change
your personality in a psychotherapeutic
setting when you're in control of the
whole thing but you take a substance and
it changes who you are I don't care if
you're happier it's changed who you are
that is a big problem for me Bill W from
who founded Alcoholics Anonymous used
LSD and he's all this literature of him
saying well the reason I stopped
drinking is because I had an experience
on LSD and I realized I didn't need it
anymore but then when they made a they
took that out because they didn't know
that story is still around but but it my
understanding is the LSD story came
later when he was struggling with
staying sober but but I don't know I
don't know that because because you're
right it's not in the big book that's
for sure but but to your point there
will be use of these things one day
there will be I'm sure of it I just
don't know how much and how to do it
yeah but dosage is key because I mean
LSD is so powerful listen I'll tell you
where it's useful is end of life dread
if you're if you have a terminal illness
and you are overwhelmed with anxiety and
Dread it's very clear that that's
helpful this I would do that this is why
I'm worried because throughout who cares
if there's an injury you know what I
mean and I really wanted to task you
this I'm really worried because the last
three years we saw how far the
government the bureaucrats big Pharma
and and doctors stood in the way of
actually helping people and treating
people and giving them early treatments
and actually doing the right thing it
makes you wonder if if they did that
three years ago because of this Health
crisis how are they doing it with other
health crises how are they doing it with
other illnesses and the opiate addiction
exactly exactly what I mean let's get
into that a little bit too because we're
uh you know we're just outside of West
Virginia right now and that's it's
really bad there they sell what's it
called Kratom Kratom is that that's for
like opiate addiction
it's just a weak opiate just changing
one for another oh it is an opiate yeah
it's a weak opiate 100 but so what
happens if people go cold turkey so they
have five days of discomfort is that it
yeah there was there was never an opiate
addict on Earth never once I'm treating
ten thousand drug addicts did I ever go
oh my God the opiate X how am I going to
get them off the opiates I never had any
problem getting them off keeping them up
we were at Blue Ridge Rock Fest
um huge Rock Festival this past weekend
and in the in the in the in the staff
artist section was a tent that said free
Narcan for artists and stuff and I was
just like dude that is brutal we should
all be carrying it around it's it's all
over the place it's just sad that you
need to hey I had an interaction when I
had to save someone's life and had to
give them CPR and thank goodness the
person turned blue I was in the car with
them and I was the only one that wasn't
driving the car and the the passenger
was was you know turning blue and just
because they they took some heroin and I
literally have to give them CPR and they
almost died this close can you explain
what causes it like when an overdose
happens what causes the death what
causes you stop breathing yeah is that
is that all it is I have to give CPR
okay and literally push air into their
life why do you stop breathing it
depresses it depresses the respiratory
drive and if you add a benzodiazepine to
it it really is very much different and
then they literally turn blue right
right what does Narcan do Narcan it
saturates the opioid receptor sites in
the brain and just pushes the opiate
away and you wake right up in fact you
go into acute withdrawal
right it's painful for people when they
get hit with Narcan because they go into
withdrawal yeah they get very agitated
and I heard it's really bad for your
organs as well no okay I've heard wrong
yeah I mean it is it has some hepatic
stuff but no no is uh Narcan would be
used even in the case of like an opioid
pill overdose
anything wow it works boom power is
Narcan an opiate it no it's an opiate
blocking it will it's in it binds it
opiate receptor sites not opiates
opiates are poppy derived right right
that's technically what opiate wow all
of them are opiates opioids are
synthetic like so fentanyl is a
synthetic uh drug does the human body
produces endorphins endorphins and then
these simulate that and flood the site
yeah yeah I mean it's I thought we went
into Afghanistan for the poppy and it's
almost laughable but like we don't need
it we got fentanyl so then so yeah what
explain fentanyl phenol is a Super Hyper
powerful synthetic opioid super powerful
and it's being manufactured in Mexico
and brought up here by the it's being
put in everything so kids are dying
accidentally people that aren't even
drug addicts are dying I heard I heard a
story recently that a woman like found a
bag and then opened it looked inside and
just passed right out yeah that those
kinds of stories I think are apocryphal
I really do I through the skin and the
inhales I I don't know don't make too
much of that but you take a a Xanax pill
that is really in fact Fentanyl and it
gets under your tongue boy that is bad
times you just die right you stop
breathing is it addictive fentanyl oh
boy profoundly I mean the hearing aids
prefer it now they prefer that's what
they go to now we have all the heroin
addicts because we created all the
opioid addicts when we were over
prescribing right yeah we just let
people have whatever they want pain
controls the patient says it is but we
were sanctioning doctors like me for
inadequate treatment of pain because I
didn't I didn't I I got in trouble
repeatedly for not giving opiates to my
heroin addicts in withdrawal because
they were uncomfortable wow can you
that's how insane it was and that was
the Joint Commission that was the
Department of Mental Health that was
California medical association I was the
VA it was ridiculous how does how does
tolerance build up happen you they think
the receptors just change their either
their configuration or their biology
slightly you need more and more to get
the same effect and then so even though
you're not feeling the effect it's still
the same threshold for death from
overdose uh for the most part the
respiratory you don't get tolerance to
that stuff yeah certainly not with
fentanyl and by the way again it's the
the deadly combo is the benzodiazepine
and the Opium and what is that what is
that valid like drugs Ativan Valium
Klonopin Ativan off the map we saw what
happened to Jordan Peterson yeah you
know
a super complicated situation he was in
what super cup what happens with the
opiate and the benzo they they're
synergistic so you can take a small
amount of opiate a small amount of
entity and you're not breathing wow so
it's not additive it's multiplied
they're they're different receptor it
just it just it just multiplies it
rather than adding the effect on
respiratory suppression it's like the
Opium Wars but done internally inside of
the United States by big Pharma well no
well look the opiates look it's China
sending it to the cartels it's it's the
it really it looks to me like what we
what England in America and the United
States did to China in the 19th century
in the Opium Wars the Opium Wars it's a
long game and they're there's just the
open Wars never ended it seems like it
doesn't it and we're not fighting it
we're doing nothing we're just like
that's what I mean to me it's more of an
inside job it drives me crazy because
yeah these people's brains are not
working right they don't when you get
them well they're like who left me like
that who did that to me I of course I
wanted to keep doing it I was a drug
addict and when you get them out you do
the it's hard to get them out of it you
need a unified team one person can't
tell you a team of people and just let
them do it they will die and now on
streets of Los Angeles is six seven a
day what would be an example of someone
suffering that you help or a group of
you help how would I do it yeah you
watch Celebrity Rehab sort of where
watch Celebrity Rehab I mean several of
those people were created during the
opioid course Jeff Conway was the poster
child for the opioid epidemic and it's
not just China I would just say you know
the United States government has a
history of importing drugs into the
United States in order to of course
[ __ ] poor populations uh one last
question because I think we're going to
Super chats do you have any comments on
seed oils because there's like a whole
bunch of personalities a whole bunch of
people talking about studies saying How
seed oils are inflammatory and they are
for you I I'm a huge fan of oh my God
I'm blanking her name now uh she wrote a
book called nutrition uh Kate Shanahan
and Kate uh help me
she's a family practitioner Dr Kate
Shanahan yeah yeah she's and she's a
biochemist and when I first and she used
to advise the Lakers to very fine
biochemist and a very fine family
practitioner and the first time I spoke
to her was probably 15 years ago and I
was like oh another nutrition thing sure
just show me the chemistry because
you're a biochemist so I'm going to make
you show me the chemistry because nobody
can and she looks at me and she goes you
can't say anything about nutrition it's
way too complicated there's certain
things I can tell you about I can talk
to you about seed oils and I can talk to
you about polyunsaturated fats when you
heat them up what happens and they cause
cancer and that's that's what I harp on
the seed oils definitely cause a big
part of them and there's a huge increase
of cancer especially when we start using
artificial seed oils canola oil
sunflower oil she thinks it's part of
the covet story too I don't know if I
went all the way there I think so too as
well especially when it comes to the gut
and the immune system because many
people said and many doctors are even
recommending kefirs and fermented food
in order to deal with covid and a lot of
doctors also thought that the the
medicine that we talked about earlier in
the show was helping people because they
got rid of parasites in their guts and
made their guts work properly which made
their immune systems work properly that
was one thesis that some doctors had so
that's that's uh we being worked out
yeah exactly we still don't know but
it's been working yeah parasites it's
bacterial balance but the gut is key to
your gut seems to be key to your health
I'm mispronouncing Kate's name what is
it it's not Shanahan it's help me is it
um
bad with pronouncing any kind of name
okay [ __ ] it's Shanahan is out spelled
okay s-h-a-n-a m-d
okay that's her okay but yeah I've been
avoiding a lot of seed oils and I've
seen an increase in my health
dramatically and it's everywhere you go
to the show everywhere listen to this I
uh I have terrible large vessel vascular
disease in my family I have lit I've uh
what's called metabolic syndrome so I'm
insulin resistant I have a hyper
triglyceridemia I'm hypertensive and I
was like I don't want my dad had
terrible vascular disease I'm like I
don't want this so I started focusing
early I got on statins early smashed my
LDL very easily but my HDL was always
low and my triglycerides were really
high until I started eating more red
meat and cutting out carbohydrates
completely and boom I mean I've never
had numbers like this good or bad really
good like really good I I uh cut out
most of the sugars I cut out bread
carbohydrates the enemy for certain
people and uh and animal fats are not as
bad as we thought exactly and they're
key for your brain I'm looking up the
coconut is they say it's a seed a nut
and a fruit but is that's not coconut
oil it's not the seed oil we're talking
about so when they say seed oil is it
like a refined Palm soy oil canola oil
sunflower oil even a lot of olive oil
and avocado oil is mixed in with these
inflammatory oils right and they're
pretend oils they're not real oils and
when you take them you think you're
taking something good and they actually
cause massive amounts of inflammation
massive amount of gut irritation instead
of the stem cell exactly that's what
I've been trying to tell him I'm like
I'm like you got fried food today I'm
like no no I had the ribeye this is
interesting because inadvertently I
would say I cut out a substantial amount
of seed oils for my diet without even
thinking about it because now like when
I make when I make eggs I used to I
would put a splash a little olive oil or
something in there now it's just bacon I
use the bacon to grease yeah
right into the bacon grease and then I
pour the bacon grease over the eggs to
make sure look at you and then I would
follow your cholesterol some people are
you know our lipid metabolism all
different one from another and just make
sure you're the person that can do that
I pour a quarter of a cup of heavy cream
into my coffee yeah so that's all my
stuff that's the awesome yeah that's I I
live that way let me tell you the most
delicious thing ever is the the mark
lobliners outright bar it's a it's a pro
it's a peanut butter protein grab one
downstairs we got a bunch we'll give it
some thank you I love it and um the
Nitro cold brew with heavy whipping
cream oh yeah and that together Nitro is
that to caveman coffee Nitro or just any
night we have Starbucks and we have hot
I think it's called high Brew but eating
that protein bar and then washing it
down with coffee which is so good but
you got to be careful the quest bars
have uh vegetables yeah yeah uh Sour
Patch Kids vegetable oils it's
everything it's crazy I literally go
down the supermarket and almost
everything has it I make sure I verbally
say it out loud so hopefully the next
person hears me I'm like oh no uh canola
oil this is cancer put it back
and I have to spend an hour extra at the
supermarket because I'm looking at the
drinking because you're yelling at
customers one of the things we've not
talked about I mentioned I think before
the mics heated up was about the
estrogens in the in all the Plastics is
that becoming increasingly convincing
that's a major part of what you think
soy boys are real I just think I think
there's a book called estrogenation that
I first got exposed to this estrogen
nation and it just uh I think that's
what it's called am I getting it there
and uh it's just free I started looking
on yeah not the way the sperm is down
reproductivity is down men are kind of
you know what I mean kids aren't having
sex anymore what the hell my boys Bill
Gates has man boobs he eats a fake meat
what do you think of course obviously
Generation estrogeneration by uh
Elizabeth wurtzel oh this is you know
what that scares me so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna eat a whole pack of bacon
for breakfast every day from now I've
heard that it's the the stuff that
they're sprouting and fruit is good too
you know it's fructose is fructose is
bad no yeah fruits are good limited
amounts fruits are good I've heard soy a
lot of it's what they're spraying on the
soy before Harvest that's delicate yeah
we got to go to super chats we have to
talk about fasting yet we will uh if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
because ladies and gentlemen oh they're
censoring us
um
if you want to hear the really stuff is
that gets censored come watch my stuff
yeah where can they find people uh let's
do Finish First oh yeah people have been
uh saying that they're not getting
notifications and so if you want to help
us combat that then you guys can be the
notification and just share the video
we're going to read super chats uh from
all you guys so find me at doctor.com
for all the pods and then doctor.tv for
the Tuesday Wednesday Thursday three
o'clock Pacific time streaming show but
that Wednesday three o'clock Pacific
time show is the one where I'm
interviewing all the Physicians that
have been silenced we're talking to them
in great detail about what happened and
putting it all together trying to figure
out what happened here and I want to say
you know now that now that you're here
and you're on the spot live we gotta
have you come back with Adam Carolla
because that would be like a millennial
Grand Slam you know we all want we all
Listen to Love Line you know with you
guys hilarious man so that'd be that'd
be really awesome but let's read Super
Chips people have questions for you
here's the important one war chicken
apoyo says Dr Drew are you a real doctor
or a love doctor that's that's a if
that's it's kind of a greeting from the
old Loveline days because I because they
would people get confused about what I
am because I do a lot of interpersonal
stuff and you know so they they think
that I'm one of these TV doctors no I've
practiced medicine for many many years
generally
agamemnon's gym bag says the Lotus
Eaters found the people accusing you of
stealing their spoons look into spoonies
and Spoon Theory I don't trust you I
don't know what that means I have no
idea that's a weird trick but by the way
I'm also I also exist at your mom's
house with Tom skier and his wife
Christina P I vote I have a new stream
as YouTube channel there the show's
called Dr director dark which is sort of
an incarnation of Loveline oh cool yeah
I love those guys that's true after dark
and so I'm part of that world I go I go
to Austin every six weeks and work with
them who's that female do you guys have
a female doctor on the show Dr Judy or
something was she around that time with
us yeah no they were trying to compete
with us I see so maybe they was just
they were on different times yeah
yeah Spoon Theory is a real thing Tim
you should look into it what is it a
metaphor describing the amount of
physical ornamental energy that a person
has available for daily activities and
tasks well I got way too much Freud
believed that Freud believed there was
like a unit of of mental ability of
mental sort of uh almost like you had
sort of a uh like a a steam engine kind
of model for the for the human brain and
you can increase it I'd imagine right I
imagine yeah I don't think I don't
necessarily adhere to that but I tell
people I don't have the bandwidth for it
right now it's a new term I use maybe
it's a little technical once you get
older I wake up and with strengths I
wake up 7 A.M I'm working by 8 A.M I
finish work around 11 pm and then I stay
up for two hours watching TV shows
and then I only go to sleep because I
know I have to I'm like if I don't go to
bed and then you know you love your work
it's at your work is your play there's
nothing better than that but I just mean
you know people people uh like accuse me
of drugs or something and I'm like just
coffee how many how many hours a night
of sleep do you need me uh at least five
and a half yeah so some people only four
or five most people need eight that's
the way it is yeah and the guys you need
four and a half they just need four and
a half that's it what do you think about
coffee is that are people overdosing on
coffee we don't know I mean every all
the I I watch coffee very carefully
because I'm a caffeine addict and I all
that data just keeps coming up positive
for a long time we thought it might have
caused pancreatic cancer that's been
completely debunked now it increases it
decreases the risk of Parkinson's and
Alzheimer's decreases risk and
depression and Humanities progression is
also correlated with the use of caffeine
really I like that see if no Civil War
we're going to get better that you guys
not depressed anymore back when that
water with clean water was hard to come
in there drink beer and yeah yeah when
they got coffee they start drinking
coffee instead and that was when the
enlightenment came oh I like that maybe
we're gonna have a new uh I think I
think I was I was also saying before the
mics heated up that when when uh
Alexander the Great's empire fell apart
stoicism came up and it's just
interesting how stoicism is coming into
the the sort of yeah what is it exactly
okay we got uh red muskrat says please
stop referring to Yin and Yang uh and
good and evil it's more still and moving
a puddle of water is Yen a tsunami is
Yang both are water I was raised Taoist
Ian would especially appreciate it great
for meditation I like it but you know
Stillness is just really fast moving
that you don't perceive
maybe that's the point Eric Christensen
says when I was homeless in New York
City 20 years ago I was offered a
one-way bus ticket to Miami by my social
worker huh I mean South Park did a whole
episode about it yeah where they put all
the homeless people on buses and send
them to the next city yep that was one
thing that was happening for a while
repopulation so now they put them on
planes
an old war punishment
gosh I was I'm you started talking about
the time and time perception I've been
listening to a lot of physics podcasts
I'm a total nerd on stuff yeah I think
the universe is twisting around on
itself rather than expanding
and that when we find a singular area
it's when we twist back towards the
center it's like a double Taurus okay
yeah we're talking about but I just
don't know the time even exists it's not
it's motion it's everything's moving
change yeah
Dan Inez says if you think the
government cares remember they spent a
decade or so telling people to eat more
bread yeah you look at the look at the
food pyramid yeah it still hasn't been
dismantled yeah it was a ridiculous and
ill-founded and without any evidence
sent down from on high and they came out
with a new one saying that Cheerios and
and frosted flakes are a lot more
healthier than red meat there's a new
there's a new food thing that they came
out with it's absolutely centralization
of authority is a bad thing of medicine
is it purely just because they want to
sell wheat because that's what we grow
I don't know who influenced them I I
just think there's a whole yeah the
court there but there was a whole story
about where the food pyramid came from
one guy invented it and he was just a
hubristic guy you know OMG puppy says
lithium in the drinking water quote
better a gram than a Dam from Brave New
World drugging the population is an old
Progressive idea from British fabians in
America in the 1920s interesting ankush
narula says Dr Drew instead of lithium
how about graphene
are you familiar with graphene
is carbon hexagonally lattice to
actually have some here everybody knows
uh I don't know about ingesting the
stuff but it's going to become the 21st
century steel building material it's
electrically conductive to be a battery
and a wire at once you can make clothing
out of even touch screen wallpapers
right now you can extract carbon dioxide
out of the air and convert it into
graphene as a building material let's go
it's happening come on DB says seeing
what happened to Tommy Loren today it's
bad yeah a civil war is here IMO and
most don't see it and don't believe it
what happened to Tommy Lauren I don't
know I just saw chaos uh at one of her
she was giving a speech and there was
violent they said violent protest
outside and I heard people yelling
did they get to her I don't know I don't
think so I imagine it would have been
that would have been the topic the
headline
someone look it up we'll see what
happens awful I'm I'm getting and my
mood's elevating those we talk here it's
better it's going to talk about time and
crafting and emotional
and Tropics
I'm trying to I'm I I really wanted to
find some good questions for you Dr Drew
so I'm just I'm kind of screening
they're not asking any good ones uh it's
mostly comments you know does anybody
have any questions about that have you
when you get into like psychoactives
like or do you think the Consciousness
is more I I personally I feel like
Consciousness is more involved with
physical health Than People realize
I don't think that the a single brain
Theory Of Consciousness is is
digging in the wrong hole I got I I
think that we like if if a feral child
who got lost in the woods at six months
comes out at 14. like remember that
movie at Eve or whatever was about with
uh she couldn't speak and I it was l or
E anyway uh sorry I don't watch movies
yeah stranger things
um no no no no long time ago but anyway
if that child came out of the woods at
15 they wouldn't be able to speak they
they wouldn't have Consciousness in the
way we think of Consciousness
Consciousness comes out as a result of
seeing ourselves reflected in other
people it's it's it's a second order
interpretation of our primary
experiences and so we can see ourselves
literally through a other pair of eyes
and we developed that through being
reflected internet videos myself it's
crazy jkg says Dr Drew Adam and Loveline
saved my life 18 years sober today and a
father to an eight-year-old daughter
thanks Drew congratulations Well Done
Right on works if you're working man
Derpy uh derp eyes says Dr Drew after
dark is based AF so glad to see him here
a conversation I never expected would
absolutely love kisses Mommy okay so so
at your mom's house they have a lot of
greetings uh calling each other mommy
jeans hey jeans hey Hitler I it's just
you have to see the videos to understand
you better be coming up in May there's
just a whole bunch of
phrases from videos we all watch anymore
so it's like the movie you were talking
about is Nell no that's it yes doc Q
says Dr Drew who's your favorite
comedian you've interviewed with ymh
have any left you speechless like the
best best-selling book by Michael
Knowles uh many have left me speechless
uh lately I uh
uh you know a Christina P I did work
with for a long time and I just really
liked the way her brain she's so smart
she's one of my favorite interviews and
uh most recently uh Tony henchler from
Kill Tony which is up right now you can
watch him and uh the skank guys like
Louis Gomez those are interesting guys
Legion of stance I went on the Legion of
skanks and I was like I was talking
about a fish out of water but I loved it
Dave Smith he's part of that he was on
the show last week yeah yeah Jen Desai
says I'd like to know what Dr Drew
thinks about transhumanism and how it
applies to the new executive order on
advancing biotechnology and
biomanufacturing and and what they have
to Define what they mean by
transhumanism
um well it's a variety of things yeah I
know what do you think about neural link
you wanna you wanna get the chip the
biggest problem with that is it's never
going to work because first of all they
have to be replaced regularly and
secondly if you drill a hole in
somebody's skull no matter how small
Nick
what do you mean Nick they're gonna
they're gonna feed it up from the neck
yeah really is that their plan I'm
pretty sure that's what they did with
pigs or whatever and monkeys and there's
very very thin wire wires that just rest
on the nerves anything touches brain it
kills cells anything so you're putting
if you could do a wireless yeah then
using magnets and stuff that we have
that we do that yeah that'd be fine
electroencephalograms uh no no we do
refer to it's uh for treatment
transcranial magnetic stimulation for
treatment of depression if you so if I
mean you say it can't be done uh uh no I
can't be done with a it can be different
technology we no no if they if they use
magnets and and uh magnetic fields then
I'm all in well I'm just saying like we
may eventually develop a technology for
some kind of conductor that wouldn't
kill the brain that allows data
transition
you plug your brain into the machine uh
oh would I do it uh as long as it didn't
take over like intermittently I think
it's very nice yeah right it's like in
uh Star Trek right now this thing's
taking over yeah I lost my I lost my
phone of the way I left it in the car
before I went over here it's the
weirdest feeling in the world now when
you lose your phone you feel completely
naked and lost this is a good one from
Diane Reynolds uh what are Dr Drew's
thoughts on mass psycho oh Mass
formation psychosis so all right you
ready I think we're experiencing it
heavily with the The Cult of the liberal
establishment there's something going on
that's for sure so this uh again I'm so
bad with names that this guy this uh
Belgium Belgium belt what they call them
he's from Belgium he's a psychologist
Belgian there we go
it's too late at night wasn't spitting
it out belgius yeah uh he came up with
this notion of the mass formation
psychosis the idea is if you have lots
of free-floating anxiety very limited
social connections and lack of meaning
that it's very easy for people to get
swept into things swept into movements
and most particularly into sort of
tribal movements that include rituals
like wearing a mask and the more those
rituals are disconnected from any
evidentiary reality the less masks are
useful the more they cling to them as a
signal of their group participation and
if you're somebody who has been been
away from a group and really feels
isolated and now here's a way to stay
connected and say I'm a part of it I
wear that mask outside you know I mean
more the more ridiculous the better to
let you know I'm all into that group and
this becomes rather psychotic right it
becomes histrionic it becomes hysterical
I I said at the very uh during Trump's I
guess probably two or three years into
Trump's Administration I kept saying
there's something going on where people
are becoming histrionic they're becoming
psychotic if if you would come to me
six seven years ago and said you know
kept talking about Nazis and you're
seeing Nazis everywhere and told me that
there was a Russian operative in the in
the Oval Office I would put you in the
hospital 5150 that is a psychotic
symptom and they're all there's a
free-floating psychi and then the
paranoia is on the other side he's
paranoid conspiracy preoccupations so
there is definitely the circumstances
that can set up a mass formation there
is definitely psychotic symptoms flying
around and back when I wrote a book
about narcissism 15 years ago I wanted
to put a chapter in about what happens
when narcissistic narcissists get
stressed and how they form mobs and then
start using Guillotines I wanted to look
at other I wanted to look at other other
examples in history only thing I could
find was the Aztecs and
pre-revolutionary France and France
being the best example of how we treat
kids very similar in pre-revolutionary
France how we traumatize kids sexual
sexual abuse physical abuse abandonment
neglect massive pandemic of that creates
a lot of PTSD and narcissism and and
cluster B personality disorders and they
tend to form mobs and act out their
aggression uh collectively like that
from what was scapegoating what if
Hitler was one of those too because he
was beat up in World War that wasn't
just him the whole country was beat up
in World War one so there was this this
you know trauma yeah and so the
scapegoating became the Jews
I think uh based on what I've seen how
people re how I I think Mass formation
psychosis something something like that
they may not be the exact uh concept but
it's a pretty good one um like there are
people that I've known my whole life
they've literally gone insane yeah and
it there's no other explanation insane
is exactly it like the things I see them
posting online the things they've said
to me I'm like you don't live in the
real world anymore yeah they it's just
it's really strange but you say like
seeing Nazis everywhere it's actually
like what we actually see in the in in
in mainstream conversations they still
believe the Russia hoax yeah there are
still it's a it's a world that was
crafted Upon A A
uh false reality and maybe it's because
of the media well the media has been
flaming it for sure social media has
been inflaming it but think about this
someone today their whole world view is
built upon six years of fake news yeah
seven years right starting with Trump's
campaign Russia hoax and all that stuff
yeah and one by one their worldview is
built upon how do you go back seven
years to correct someone's shattered
psyche you can't you get such powerful
cognitive dissonance and you you can see
it when they start attacking the person
who who exposes them to this right the
ad hominem arguments tells you the
cognitive dissonance has been triggered
I think I think part of it is that
um humans are scared to be wrong for a
variety of reasons well we're wired this
way we are we are what we are wired
against is any change to our physical
being but it turns out the same uh
resistance to change of our physical
beating is wired into our self the self
can't be changed and part of the self is
our belief system what I I was I read
this a long time ago and and I I don't
know exactly what it was it's been too
long but it's that you know our mind is
developing until the array until about
the age of 24 is that is that right
around there 24 to 28 or something
that's true but it's about true well
that man 27 28 really but that's like
and then you're an adult and then your
brain stops yeah and uh I was reading
about why people have
um emotional breakdowns and panic
attacks and things like that and they
said humans evolved to defend their
worldview because if you've made it to
the age of 25 you've succeeded whatever
it is you were doing succeeded you
survived you survived and this will keep
you alive and your children if this is
wrong and it breaks you are now at risk
so what happens is humans who would make
dramatic changes at some point in their
life would have a lower success rate and
be more likely to die not not
definitively but it's just basic
attrition from an evolutionary
perspective you're right yes over a long
enough period of time those that were
firm in their beliefs were more likely
to survive correct so if someone is say
35 years old and they've built their
worldview and then you enter into logic
that is indisputable and and it breaks
that it puts them at risk of of not
surviving and thus they they Retreat to
an emotional space of anger to try and
reject what you've said because it will
make them less likely to survive and
religion was always a big part of that
and people fought Wars over these things
and now the new religion is political
and so we are coming on to coming up to
seven years now of fake news hoaxes yeah
and there are people today who believed
that story from seven years ago about
Russia and the alpha bank and all that
they still believe it they will not
entertain reality and there is no way
for us to rewind the clock seven years
of someone I mean seven years every cell
in your body they say has changed your
whole being is built on a fictitious
reality I don't see how you solve that
problem
wait seven years over your Center seven
more years of correcting it we'd have to
shut down uh we have to we have to it's
going to be longer than that CNN's you
know they're they're aren't going
they're transforming dramatically we
have to gain a sphere of influence to
the point where it's undeniable what do
you mean by that reality is undeniable
the Russian who needs to get a sphere
you need atmosphere people people who
are not psychotic people are connected
to reality yeah yeah concentric spheres
yes yes need to can gain control over
the like and I don't mean any one person
centralizing control I'm saying the
systems of influence need to be
overwhelmingly run by those who are in
objective reality that is the Russia
gate stuff was a hoax Trump wasn't a
Russian agent there's not Nazis
everywhere the the total amount of white
supremacists in the country according to
I think the ADL I'm not sure it's like
10 000 people not several million like
the media is lying about once these big
networks like Vox which claimed they
said like millions of people were white
supremacists or shared those views it's
insane once they lose influence and stop
this then these people who are
experiencing Mass formation psychosis
might be forced out rather painfully I
might add but it's the only way to get
someone out of a cult you have to remove
them from the culture and cut off their
connection but sometimes they have it
but but oftentimes but this is a really
interesting point I've not thought of it
this way if you if you look at it
through the prism of cult there's often
a I forget what they call it like when
things rush in when there's a sudden
fully uh sort of a collapse of their
cult views and a rush in of reality it's
it's uncomfortable it's painful it takes
a while to adjust to it but it's not a
slow process it's a fast process I was
listening to a podcast the way in here
about the the JFK uh sort of conspiracy
theory was a guy who is a conspiracy
theorist most of his young life and then
started actually reading the reports of
what what you know what the evidence was
one way or the other and it all of a
sudden just crushed in on him one day
and he had to change his whole outlook
in one day and that's very common with
cultish kinds of use so I I it may
happen all at once to people one at a
time because of cell phones these people
can can always reconnect with the cult
to reaffirm their cult worldview yeah
and that's a scary reality yes all right
we got this from Jay crane O2 says
former opioid user I was shot in
Afghanistan by a sniper and was put on
oxycodone and took me over seven years
to get off nearly killed myself over the
withdrawal I'm sorry Suboxone is that he
pronounce it yep saved my life vets are
dying
so what I was gonna say I when I when I
was uh in 26 20
14. I had a kidney stone they gave me
Percocet I took one and it was the most
intense feeling I have ever had and I
never took another pill and I Good
Feeling got rid of it yeah yeah it was
but but as good as I felt once I was
done I was terrified yeah and I just
never took one well if you learn how
different the biology one brain versus
another is so I had you know big surgery
I told you about earlier and I had to
take some Percocet afterwards I hated it
I felt awful I couldn't stand it really
that's different biology I I gotta tell
you it I I it it's it's an it was
Indescribable the feeling yeah a lot of
people I hope it addicts can't cannot
literally can't believe that I didn't
like it that's like incomprehensible to
that I would I would describe it as like
a uh sharp Good Feeling acute it was
like there was a ball of warmth and love
and energy and my core radiating to
every every fiber of my body warm
blanket mother those sorts of feelings
yeah I get the opposite yeah I got sort
of dysphoric and awful and beautiful and
I and I looked at it and I was like I
know exactly why this kills people and I
never took it cannabis does that to some
people too that's when they get addicted
to it alcohol as well they got a
pleasure Center for men same thing same
phenomena not booze does not doesn't do
that for me but uh Suboxone medically
assisted treatment excellent it helps it
save some lives it's uh I it's sort of
overdone and people are encouraged to
get off it soon enough and there's
problems with it but it saves lives no
doubt regarding uh Mass formation I
wonder if you've noticed this phenomenon
of people saying right after some
they'll make a statement it's been about
five or six years I've noticed it very
much in the last two where they'll be
like they'll be talking to you right and
they'll say something that you know the
UFO is floating right and and they say
right as if it's almost like a cult
identifier or or like they're not
confident that what they're telling you
is real I have noticed myself that I
always have to check in with people and
make sure they're hearing me I don't
know if it's because of the acrimony
that's out there I always find myself
going am I making sense do you hear me
did you understand what I'm saying
because there's so much conflict
triggered by just by misunderstanding
each other that's where that's where I
check in like that so there's a there's
like a fear like a sociological fear
that people aren't that you know they're
hearing us they're not hearing us I
noticed you know I've been studying
French lately and they're very big on
saying do you see do you see constantly
they say that uh and so and I caught my
ear because then when I was when I
studied French when I was younger I
didn't didn't remember them saying that
so it's happening there too interesting
right yeah yeah hey by the way French
have been very intriguing I don't know
if you've been following what happened I
wasn't I was in Paris a year ago and the
youth were in the streets demonstrating
against the overreach of the government
I was like whoa their whole thing was
hey you told us this illness isn't so
bad for us as a young person a thin
young person but you're gonna 4 forces
to take a vaccine with unknown potential
consequences that is not liberte that's
not that's not what this country is
founded on I was like wow how appealing
to have young people fighting for their
for the principles upon which the
Republic was founded there's a lot of
protests globally but they were just
censored and no one was supposed to know
about them well you did you didn't know
in this country was the opposite they
wanted more masking more of this more of
that it's like oh my God woo
all right Kane IV says would any of the
modern day psychosis have any relation
to the collective unconscious
well you know first you have to say is
there a collective unconscious I I
believe there's a collective something
for sure and the collective something
has been going in a certain direction
lately yes and it has contributed to
this this General whatever this is yes
for sure I I don't it's not even a
collective unconscious but it's
certainly a state that we are all in
it's brain entrainment have you heard of
this entrainment phenomenon yeah
external stimuli will alter the way that
the brain yeah it does but it's it's
really look we've scared an entire world
we do we lock down a world it's just
Unthinkable things we've been through of
course there's going to be effects on it
but it started before this though I mean
you're right it started six years ago
with yeah with Trump it's like it's like
all Trump derangement or something or
that triggered it or started it or
something and and and now it's not Trump
anymore it's it's become a general
derangement syndrome well also you know
I think there was an Obama derangement
syndrome too I remember some of the
weird stuff people would send me about
him I was like come on and then and then
it escalated with Trump and then it
really went why wild during covet all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends I can look at the
analytics we have for the show and I can
clearly tell something has been going on
especially this past week especially
today and we're getting a ton of
messages from people who are saying they
can't find it in search the
notifications aren't popping up some
people say they've watched every episode
since the show started and this is the
first time they haven't got
notifications
there you go I ended it the Phoenix
Rises brother if you want to help out
you can be the notification and just
share timcast.com where the live video
player goes up every night on the home
page because maybe they'll censor the
YouTube link or something who knows but
sharing the the video player and the
channel encouraging people to watch it
if you do like it is the most powerful
thing you can do you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me at
timcast Dr Drew do you want to shout out
anything yeah I do I yeah my my wife
produces uh my streaming shows with uh
with our webmaster uh Caleb nation and
they were all over me like this is so
amazing here at the gym you're at the
tip guys make sure you talk about the
shows so I have a bad promoter so let me
try to do my best here which is we do a
streaming show on Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday at three o'clock Pacific time
our Wednesday shows I think will be very
particularly interesting to you people
because we are I'm with there with Dr
Kelly Victory who's one of the people
that have been silenced and
de-platformed we don't always agree on
everything which what makes it
interesting and then she and I interview
the people that have all been Jay
bhattacharya and mellow all the names
you've heard I we interview them all all
of them and really get and repeatedly as
time goes on and uh Adam and Drew I've
been Adam Andrew Drew show I have a
doctor who podcast uh and then I have
the your mom's house Dr Jeff it's all
doctor.com TV please come on over I'd
love to see the Tim cast world over
there be fantastic that'd be cool yeah
thanks for coming appreciate it I I do I
have to go no we gotta talk about
terrain Theory well terrain Theory I was
so depressed foreign
I'm so impressed that people come out
here I love that they come to you you
know what I mean far away this is far
away this is far away but we we pay to
fly people in but but they come and that
to me I was I I wanted to be here and I
thought wow all these people come that's
that is a really significant endorsement
of what you're doing so congratulations
appreciate it man yeah so you most
people can't get people to do this and I
and I'm going to tell you this too I
mean listening to Loveline every night
when I was a kid you've had a big
influence on Me growing up and I think
it must be weird for you you know you're
you're older you walk in them and the
first thing I was like hey nice to meet
you I was like I used to listen to your
show all the time when I was a kid when
I was a kid or my mom loves you or my
grandmother loves you which even worse
but yeah but all right look to me it's
it's uh I've had this extraordinary life
I've had this extraordinary clinical
experience this Media stuff where did
this come from it was all just the
serendipitous thing that happened to me
I never planned any of it are your
patients like is it weird for them to
like your doctor Dr Drew and so so I
have two you know most all my medical
patients I followed for 20 years and
they're like go go get them do your
thing you know they're and they're all
now in their 75 and plus you know a lot
of them are uh so that doesn't bother
them on the addiction medicine side you
know I ran a big program you know in a
hospital with very sick patients with
Shelly and Bob and all the people you
saw in Celebrity Rehab and these
patients would come in they would say
you know I was watching this show and I
realized I couldn't deny it any longer
and they're like and you were there and
you were there like Wizard of Oz and
then after to a person they go oh well
good you can help me let's just help me
yeah I want to feel better and and that
was it that's so nothing ever really
comes of it otherwise which is nice and
so I can live in two I live in a lot of
very different worlds and I am so
grateful so back to your point about
making a difference that's all I've ever
wanted to do is make a difference help
people and that's it and to say that
I've done that is uh I'm very grateful
well this was a this was a great
conversation and I think it also helped
a lot of people so thank you so much for
coming on I really appreciate it thank
you for of doing your research and
co-signing all the stuff I was doing
absolutely going on about and uh Tim
listen to him listen to him a little bit
come on now that's why he's here yeah
thank you appreciate that my website is
Lucan sensor.com and man I really love
to talk about the health stuff I wish we
could talk about it more and I think
they censor it because it actually is
really important and it helps a lot of
people I talk about it a lot and my own
personal health journey in my latest
video Luke uncensored.com hope to see
some of you guys there and Ian if you
make a pledge right now I will work out
with you with a soldier fit Danny from
Soldier fit once a week right now every
Friday you win uh I'm gonna need to look
at the concert
self-defense training it sounds
phenomenal that's the contrast about the
contract as long as I don't there's no
other like now run a mile I'm you know
we'll figure it out hey hey hey
it's work cardio is good yeah there's a
lot of a lot of things are working I
mean technically we're all working right
now I laid out the contract it's simple
it's plain yes or no and I'm totally
into this so yes let's look into it
further that's gonna get bumped Ian
think of the fans I'm gonna get ripped
I'm gonna pick my girlfriend up and
carry around the room while we're having
we can make a video series I want you to
you know I want to imagine right now how
you looked when you're doing that
training montage for the MTG so skinny
and gross now Nick imagine your neck
just three times no dude and you're just
Russell Brand no that's that's how Rusty
Rockets got so hot is because he's
working out you know taking care of his
body that's right we could do a video
series think of the fans I only hope
that next time we get to talk about germ
Theory and terrain Theory and Rain
Theory terrain Theory I've heard of this
yeah the germ theory is that there's a
germ that flows through the air gets on
you and duplicates whereas the train
there is if your body's in the in the
right physiological State The Germ will
proliferate but if it's in a different
state The Germ won't be able to
proliferate okay love you man and also
like Tim Loveline really kind of helped
guide me in my early I was like 12 and I
learned about sex ed well and and I
started the show really started because
of HIV and AIDS I I we weren't even
calling it aids yet and we didn't have a
causative agent but no one was talking
to young people about it that was really
what motivated me to go do it and I
treated I was deep in the AIDS epidemic
during the time and by the way in terms
of pandemics that one had a 100 fatality
rate all never wrong we tell people that
six months to live and we were never
wrong think how different that is than a
one percent fatality rate but anyway
um and so it motivated me to come in and
the notion I had when I came I was like
24 years old and I thought God this
stuff is so easy for people to
understand just no one tells young
people they need to just understand and
I just if it is what I would have wanted
when I was 14. that was the idea love
you man see you buddy
thank you guys very much for tuning in
this evening this was an incredibly fun
conversation with Dr Drew we will have
to have you back please
we're gonna have him he's super busy too
I know you are as well we're bringing
him is not you got to coerce him and um
what's his favorite food
uh let me think of some things you can
do okay well we'll have like a throne
chair with everything like he likes a
cigar and like the right pizza there
might be something we'll have a little
Crown you can put it on there might be a
way to do it I really would love to have
Adam and you together we should reprise
this for sure you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com at Sour Patch Lids as
well asapachlips stop me we're going to
have a picnic tomorrow so I hope you all
have a really good weekend thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all on
Monday